so
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
to
[Laughter]
[Music]
my
[Laughter]
my
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
so
my
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody
why the [ __ ] it seemed like it was gonna
go again
that was really weird i got the damn
volume on this oh that's what it was it
was you yeah i'm sitting there going
what the [ __ ] is it looping i'm pretty
sure i had that turned off
yeah so today is open lines friday
so it's black friday black friday did
anybody actually does anybody in their
right mind actually go out on black
friday
and buy [ __ ]
i know that some people like to they're
just kind of like hey we're gonna get up
at like five in the morning and go wait
in line outside of best buy or whatever
guess it depends on where you live and
how much money you have and what you
want
it just doesn't seem all that fun to me
and i mean it's i mean you know because
i don't really like being around a lot
of people anyway and i don't like
getting up early
i give a [ __ ] about retail goods that's
the problem well the thing about it is
that i would rather like pay a little
bit more and have [ __ ] delivered to my
house so i don't have no place right
they're selling what i don't give a [ __ ]
about that yeah i mean you know [ __ ]
ever since i was a little kid they sold
these little trinkets they were even
[ __ ] commercials for them if you look
at what they were selling back in the
70s like old 70s commercials you're like
i can't believe people bought that well
guess what you're buying the same
[ __ ] thing
it's just a modernized version of that i
feel like everybody just wants to go buy
like tvs and i'm like well we are we
have a bunch of tvs already
it's like you know some people need them
that's true
the only thing i bought today i bought
online
and i bought
um
i bought a ring light you know one of
those lights that go around the camera
but you can clip it on the top of your
thing
uh to kind of like [ __ ] with the
lighting a little bit more does it work
better well i don't know that's what
like a lot of people have those all
right like for podcasting
and uh we'll see what it if it makes my
face look prettier okay
because the light in here is kind of
like weird but i like it but it's kind
of like weird like especially on the
faces like sometimes i'm kind of like
the shadows are kind of harsh yeah it
was only it was 15 bucks it was on sale
so that was the only thing i bought
today oscar says that that siren whale
in the intro is freaky yeah that's why
we did that [ __ ] jenny was looking for
some creepy [ __ ] why did you put that on
yeah i love creepy [ __ ] yeah uh danny
rolling ghostface says that bruce
campbell black friday film was kind of
lame but original just saying yeah i've
heard about that i was like i'll watch
anything with bruce campbell in it
though i mean he makes everything good
oscar says uh asks have you guys seen
the movie the cook the thief in his life
yes i've never seen it i have seen it
yeah it's really really good actually i
wanted to see it somebody else brought
it up or i was reading something
oh i know i was like reading a movie
review about another movie i'd watched
and they compared it to that and so i
was like uh yeah i need to rewatch that
because i remember that being really
good
um
uh oh somebody saw a resident evil
welcome to raccoon city that's out
already that's a new one yeah
i saw that we saw the trailer but i
thought it wasn't out until later i want
to see that new uh see that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] amc i want to go i want to see
um
nightmare alley that new guillermo del
toro one but i don't think that starts
until the middle of december though so
was resident evil any good
yeah well
said it was short but good all right
honestly i saw did i even see the first
resident evil i feel like i saw the
first one
and i don't even know how many there
were
and i never played the games
so
i'm not much of a gamer i always kind of
like wanted to get into it but i don't
know i just don't have time
i kind of you know i got so many movies
i got to watch i got so many books i got
to read i don't really have time to
play video games because i know i'd get
like all involved in it
oscar said i'd love it but i'm not sure
what he's talking about must be talking
about the thief movie
it's uh i remember it being pretty um
pretty weird what is it about
um [ __ ] man what was it about
i remember it being kind of like an arty
flick but also cannibalism
i've been wanting to go back and see the
early 80s movie thief
remember they had the [ __ ] had that damn
i think it was james cohn wouldn't it
was it what was it about refresh my
memory i don't know it was about thief
and it had a damn
um
the uh soundtrack was by tangerine dream
it was supposed to be badass when it
came out did i say that never seen it
there's a couple of money to see i want
to see thief
i want to see
bullet i've never seen that
i've never seen any uh any of that
dude's movies what's his name
[ __ ]
not james what's up motherfucker's name
dude it was in a bullet
steve mcqueen steve mcqueen i've never
seen any of his movies wasn't he in the
great escape i've never seen that
you've never seen the great escape nope
that seems like the quintessential dude
movie or one of the quintessential dude
movies never seen it i've even seen that
and i'm a girl yeah
no i've never seen any steven queen
movies but i keep hearing about steve
mcqueen you didn't even see the original
blob
i saw that okay he was in that okay he
was supposed to be a teenager even
though he's yeah that's the only steve
mcqueen
which doesn't really count
i mean you know
i know but um
i do know that [ __ ] stephen queen was
a [ __ ] dude though he was definitely
just like a [ __ ] real dude
back in the 70s 60s and 70s he was big
into hot rods and motorcycles
and he was living out in california all
the little custom hot rod shops made
[ __ ] for him
and any of his cars
uh uh their his cars are still swimming
around in the collector's scene you know
what i mean he had cars made for him
and if you've got one it's worth a lot
of money
he'd have the best
because you know back in the day a
factory car
didn't have everything he wanted on it
it's really supposed to be modded out to
get the best performance out of it
so mcqueen he'd buy a car and send it
directly to these shops to have a modded
out with the best [ __ ] you could
possibly have you know including super
charging and turbo charging and all the
best aftermarket stuff
and uh
he'd have his like a steve mcqueen
special version of that car
and uh they're out there
guys that [ __ ] owned those shops
remembered where they were
you know kept track of them as he'd sell
them off
and they're worth a lot of money
and it just might be something weird you
know like a
like a porsche or something or uh
just a ferrari that he bought back in
the 60s or 70s
and um you know
if you don't want to steve mcqueen's
cars you're the [ __ ] german said wasn't
he in the towering inferno
wait was he we've never seen it i've
never seen terms well i've seen it but
it i saw it back in the [ __ ]
late 70s yeah like when i was a kid i
remember oj was it what oj in it i don't
know i think oj i've never seen it now
we recently watched the poseidon
adventure yeah he wasn't in that no no
he definitely wasn't in that but um
yeah gene hackman was in that yeah and
ernest borgnine was in that and shelly
winters
um
and the dude that played uh charlie
bucket's grandpa and willy wonky yeah
yeah
he's a he was a good character
um
but yeah we meant to like go off into
that into all the disaster movies and
actually the towering inferno was the
next one we were going to watch
i thought well no because i've been
wanting to watch orca too maybe we can
watch it tonight if i if we're not so
drunk that we don't know what's like
happening in it yeah orcma says dude he
said tom you need to see the great
escape yeah i know i i keep hearing
about it
it's really good yeah i mean yeah it's a
classic you really didn't even see it i
got to get on on the mcqueen movies
yeah i know i know about the dude i've
never seen his movies though it's weird
because even
i don't know if i would necessarily
consider myself like a cinephile in the
way that some people are where they've
seen like every [ __ ] thing ever yeah
um
but it's weird because a lot of times
like when we bring up this or that movie
most of them i've seen
it's just that
i saw a lot of them when i was younger
um and you know as i got into my teenage
years and stuff i went more into like
horror and you know kind of like weird
cult movies and stuff so sometimes i
miss out on stuff but i've seen
i mean most of the classics i've seen
most of those at one time or another
straw dog says it's weird that i
mentioned thief and bullet
at the same time because he's seen them
both he always thought they were very
similar yeah i've never seen either one
of them
i just i've seen bullet but i don't
think i've seen thief though i've seen
like uh
just like quick clips of both of those
movies and they look like a kind of
movie i would like oh i'm sure you and i
remember seeing the uh
the trailers for them you know
and uh
it just bullet looked like something
right up my alley i've just never seen
it
it's a retro movie
you know back in the day movie but it
he's [ __ ] terrorizing around up in
the hills of california on this [ __ ]
badass mustang and
mcqueen looking cool and [ __ ] i don't
know what it's about he's got a [ __ ]
gun with a [ __ ] under shoulder
holster
and then look like james khan and d
[ __ ] cut and [ __ ] with sparks flying
and
[ __ ]
tangerine dream music playing and he's
got his goggles on he's kind of cutting
through a wall or a safe trying to get
to something it'd just look like a good
they both look like real good movies
look like something i need to see
yeah you need to start you need to start
keeping a list like i have yeah like
every time somebody suggests something
well most of the time when people
suggest they were before my time they
were before my time you know that's no
excuse yeah
they were before my time i'd never seen
i've seen a lot of movies that were and
liked a lot of movies that were before
my time if you only stuck to stuff that
was of your time you'd be missing out on
a lot of [ __ ] um
yeah sheila anne's a terrible movie
terrain with paul newman and uh also
points out that orca has bo derek yeah i
thought she i thought she was in that
well we wanted to see towering inferno
as part of our disaster kick yeah 70s
desserts like i said we were poseidon
adventuring and
towering inferno and then i wanted to
see some more like nature run amok
movies like the swarm and stuff
so
when we were kids empire the ants we
grew up and they were constantly hitting
us with them disaster movies one after
airport airport 77 you know like
earthquake avalanche yeah
and you're like what the [ __ ] every one
of them was like the world was ending
that was coming out we were little kids
you go to school and little kids like oh
man you seen an earthquake holy [ __ ]
it's an earthquake you never know when
an earthquake is the earth shaking we
all died anything about that you know
just [ __ ] funny [ __ ] you know
and uh
disaster films were [ __ ] hurt 70s
that was 70s as [ __ ]
yeah like i said disaster any kind of
like nature run amok movies yeah
although disaster movies also shaded
into like shipwrecks and things like
that but sometimes it was natural
disasters
shipwrecks yeah all that kind of [ __ ]
volcanoes blowing up
if the the resorts on an island the
islands get swallowed up by the ocean
that yeah that kind of [ __ ] like i said
i actually i just watched uh part of
avalanche yesterday because it was on
the they did it on the newer the netflix
mst3k and they that was on part of their
turkey day marathon that was the one
with uh mia farrow and dermot also
brought up the deep that was jacqueline
bissett wasn't it i remember liking that
a lot too that was kind of like they
were diving for
pirate treasure right or like buried
treasure something like that
john smith says the great escape is a
surprising classic in the uk for some
reason we always watch it at christmas
or easter don't ask me why
world war ii trump i guess i don't know
the thing with the uh
the thing with disaster movies
i remember
the hook the hook was is that you got to
see all of your favorite
[ __ ] stars they would all be in the
same movie there might be 20 of them
you may not see them for very long
but they were all in there that's what
the hook was if you wanted to see them
all kind of like get killed in really
horrifying ways right
yeah so they were an all-star cast and
it seemed like the movie was and with
the the
the trailers forum was like it was a
[ __ ] huge event because every [ __ ]
star was in this movie each one for two
minutes but yeah
yeah that's until they got sucked into
the earth or whatever that was
or got sucked out the plane window
i guess i guess the stars liked him
because they could just show up and do a
couple hours work and get [ __ ] 10
grand
yeah probably yeah however much they
paid them back then it's like they show
up it's like you guys got free liquor on
the craft table all right let's let's do
this [ __ ]
all right i jump in the water
oh god oh the bahamas are eating me i'm
like all right give me my 10 grand i'm
out of here
that's probably what it was yeah of
course dear friend on hollywood squares
well i was you know i was gonna say
funny you mentioned hollywood squares i
said do you remember back in the old
days when they used to have those big
special events a few times a year the
battle of the network stars do you
remember that same show where they would
take kind of all their biggest stars
from whatever shows they had
and they would teach them like circus
tricks yeah play like kind of like
dancing with the stars before dancing
with the stars yeah do tricks and
[ __ ] it's like yeah let's teach linda
blair how to do like uh trapeze yeah
kind of [ __ ]
or walk on a tightrope
it was just like it just it's like the
weirdest [ __ ] ever now that like you
think about it at the time nobody really
thought it was weird i guess they were
trying to invent material but yeah was
it okay was it a competition between the
stars from each network like the cbs
people were pitted against the abc
people
was it yeah if i remember correctly i
don't remember it being like a
competition but i guess it was because
battle of the network stars they had all
kinds of weird [ __ ] they would have big
[ __ ] like
luaus at certain times of the [ __ ]
year where they'd have the big hawaiian
motif and everybody sitting up on a
stage it was kind of like the merv
griffin show and you had all these
guests talking and then these [ __ ]
crazy ass acts and everybody's watching
it happen there's a damn audience and
they got tables the audience are sitting
on tables watching it happen and it's
all being televised because that's the
way a nightclub was back in the 70s yeah
there's like those around the table
variety shows like a variety show and it
would be like
have something to do with like you know
a certain time of the year you have
sammy davis jr up there [ __ ] talking
and yeah man it was it was round it was
it
outside you know all the different guys
and then was
[ __ ] talking and girls [ __ ] you
know
and it everything it was
boobs and [ __ ] legs and [ __ ] it was
it was kind of a sexy time in a way but
it was just like it was a sexy time it
was
people were [ __ ] kind of freewheeling
and they were like yeah man pass me the
joint man you know and then they were
just
and they were drinking in the audience
and they were drinking up on stage
and it'd be like a tv special remember
those things yeah
and they would just make up a damn event
a special event
and it was the setting was it was like a
talk show slash a club
a 1970s 1960s nightclub
and they'd do little acts and [ __ ] and
they'd give them [ __ ] impressive
names and i can't remember any of them i
just remember them in general happening
but i don't remember the names of any of
them i remember that i mostly remember
the battle and network stars one yeah
because for some reason i always want to
watch that because i was just kind of
like yeah let's see all these sitcom
stars fall off a [ __ ] trapeze yeah
for some reason that was really funny to
me or like ride an elephant
it makes sense looking back on it though
because there was no social media so
that's what the social media was that
they'd have parties we needed something
to entertain us god damn it you kids
today you have no idea right they'd have
a party on live tv with all the [ __ ]
stars on the in the party basically is
what it was and then get there and sing
and [ __ ]
that would be super funny if we did a 13
o'clock
battle of network stars thing where we
did like where we had to learn how to do
like circus tricks and whatever like
yeah swallowing swords
or whatever the [ __ ] i don't think they
ever did that they didn't do any of the
like kind of the
the freak show or sideshow stuff did
they it was mostly like riding elephants
getting in the in the cage with tigers
you know like sick freedom right kind of
[ __ ] it's been a long time trappies i
remember that kind of stuff it's kind of
like uh
what do you call that [ __ ] like the
gladiators remember those gladiator
[ __ ] um
television shows yeah we had to run
across obstacles and [ __ ] hit things
and [ __ ] get scores and
that was that didn't last long there was
one caller yeah american gladiators like
that that was actually more like yeah
that was like one against another kind
of yeah yeah because i remember
i don't know it's i don't remember i
kind of remember it but i remember mst
making a couple jokes about it because i
remember one of the chicks was named
blaze
they weren't that great i never watched
any of that [ __ ] no i didn't really
see it that was a little bit after that
was 90s right i feel like that was the
90s they were trying to i think [ __ ]
do running man
yeah essentially basically
yeah they're trying to run a man
from like arnold schwarzenegger arnold
schwarzenegger's version of the running
man yeah it was like that but you know
they were hitting each other with like
just big foam [ __ ] full things
there's no one was really getting
nowhere near as good as like the
japanese original well yeah because the
japanese didn't really give a [ __ ] if
people got hurt or not
called tashigi's castle i think is what
it was called
uh then they [ __ ] rebooted it here
they did an american version do you
remember what that thing was called
where they just had japanese people
[ __ ] these dumbass costumes trying to
run across these weird obstacle courses
and do these [ __ ] crazy things that
look like pirates or castles and i kind
of remember that
i kind of remember that
tashigi's castle i think is i think the
real name of it but i think they renamed
it for for the us
well yeah nobody's going to watch
something called over here well nowadays
they would but back then they wouldn't
have
um oscar perez says oh we're doing the
drinking game thing again
uh take a shot every time jenny mentions
mst again you'll probably get uh liver
failure before the end of the show well
because you gotta mention it around
thanksgiving because you know they did
the turkey day marathon yesterday and
they said all the new episodes
that they're going to do for their
season 13 that they paid for with the
kickstarter john smith says to she's
castle the show was so difficult it's an
entire run only about six people ever
won yeah i think that's right they had
to get through all these damn challenges
i don't think anybody ever made it yeah
right but you forget that people don't
made it don't make it just because it's
just hilarious well yeah you just wanted
to see people like eat [ __ ] you know you
didn't really want to see people win
and the american version had like it was
dubbed in english so you had like
american announcers
[ __ ] talking about what was happening
oh and she falls and yeah it's just
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] no [ __ ]
did she really
yeah
well they're you know they're being
sports announcers you know and they're
just
people running and jumping from one
thing to the next and they're [ __ ]
like
jumping on little moving [ __ ]
platforms that are suspended above a
bunch of pudding or something you know
just [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] so gross yeah
it's just like what was that [ __ ] on uh
nickelodeon double dare
where they had that but that was like
for kid well was it kids or that was
like your whole family i think i
remember kids and some of them were like
kids and their parents and you had to do
like all kinds of gross
[ __ ]
i don't know i can't i have a hard time
like i can watch
certain kinds of gross things all day
long
but
for some reason like whenever they had
something in double there where people
had to like wrestle in
pudding or something that just grosses
me out or cream corn i'm just like no
thanks i'm just that's nasty like i'll
eat it but i'm not gonna watch people
like roll around it that's like
disgusting
so you went to
the
biker bar today yeah i went there you
have your ring on i see yeah so you do
so you didn't get in trouble with your
with your with your girlfriend my other
girlfriend yeah she was in there she
wasn't there today
i go in there and there's just it's just
like dudes and some chick working there
and just
drinking um
tequila
having a good time a bunch of
motorcycles coming in and out because
it's kind of a holiday today because
after thanksgiving yeah the black friday
so it was it was a motorcycle motorcycle
day
and i was talking to some dude
sitting next to me
who is uh
um one of the
i guess he's one of the salesmans over
at the local ford dealership and he said
oh yeah i'll get you a car you know
that's it i'll take your ford jenny's
ford
trade i'll get you a mustang you know
it's just saying everything that they
have over there i mean does he know what
what a kind of piece of crap my car is
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter he
can give you like
between 500 and a thousand depending on
what it is that you buy from him he said
he could hook us up but uh
he said brand new cars are not coming
because there's some kind of
problem with resistors or something or
they can't complete cars right now so
there's a lot of used cars and they're
kind of drying up
so uh supply chain supply chain he says
that's that's for true
cars aren't really being made i think he
said it was capacitors or something a
flux capacitor flex capacity so we can't
travel through time
oracle says speaking of movies from
before our time uh asking me have i ever
seen burn witch burn i have and matter
of fact
i think i did a review of it not too
long ago like maybe a couple months back
yeah that was actually really really
good i had never i don't think i had
ever seen it prior to seeing it because
i think shutter had it on there i don't
know if it's on there anymore but i
watched it and did a review of it a
while back it's really really good
yeah cam guy says all car dealerships
only have five or ten new cars that's
what he said says that their their
selection of new cars is [ __ ] like
slam to slim pickings he says he's never
seen it this bad
well i can't afford a new car anyway so
i'm not gonna worry about it
they'd be desperate to sell you a new
car
well unless they're going to give it to
me for free yeah
if they give it to me for free then
maybe we can talk call me up but
uh yeah
uh careful with the used cars a lot of
those flooded cars are showing up now
um
yeah uh oracle says uh have you read the
book it's based on conjure wife i
haven't but i've read other books by
that author
um that's it's fritz lieber right fritz
lieber for its library
um i've read some of his other stuff and
some of his short stories and that was
one that i always kind of meant to get
to
so i will eventually
uh john smith says ever seen the love
witch yes uh that was
excellent not exactly a horror movie but
it had like a lot of horror elements to
it it was really cool you'd probably
like it it's kind of like
it's made to look like an old
like a retro almost like a giallo movie
but it's sort of set in the present day
but
it's kind of like
not you know what i mean but the way
it's shot is like really really
beautiful but it's just like about this
girl that's a witch and she's kind of
like yeah but it's really it's actually
really cool not super horry it's kind of
i don't know i don't know what i'd call
it
it's sort of horror
i think they have it on
shutter had it
i don't know if it's on there anymore
but i think you can get it on
uh
i think it's on 2b it might be on 2b for
free
oh you know what i just noticed i went
to 2b earlier today because i was
watching another movie that i was going
to review in a couple weeks and they
just added naked lunch
i haven't seen that in a long time i
haven't seen that a long time either i
had that on vhs back in the old days i
don't know what happened to it yeah that
was a weird ass [ __ ] movie yeah i
read the book it wasn't yeah i did too
unreadable
he couldn't stay on subject he couldn't
stay on topic he's [ __ ] well [ __ ]
at least you at least you like he was
we're cognizant of that you were like oh
wait
oh yeah no he's trying to he's trying to
write a story and then he forgets about
the story that he's writing and that
writes another story look at this girl
this [ __ ] can't finish the story
he's just hi you could tell he was high
yeah there's well i mean there's kind of
a fine line between
something that seems like
uh it's not related but it actually is
related like on another level and then
there's
you know
dude that's just kind of like stone and
it's just kind of like i kind of got
sick of that let's talk about this now
he's [ __ ] stoned
beezna says the clockwork orange book is
unreadable i did not find it unreadable
maybe because
i guess because i saw the movie first i
think did i
i kind of feel like i saw the movie
first
um and then read the book so
the the slang in there wasn't
uh unfamiliar there's a there's a
there's a dictionary in the back yeah
there's a glossary in the background but
a lot of the words i f i found that you
could figure them out from just like
context you know what i mean yeah she
said glossary it was a dictionary it's a
glossary okay
okay it's not a whole a dictionary is a
whole big [ __ ] dictionary yeah it's a
glossary that's just like terms we used
in this [ __ ] here here's what they all
need
you can understand each day you can
understand what they're talking about
yeah i mean like i said most of it there
was a couple ones that i had to look up
but most of the ones you could kind of
get it from like context clues and stuff
um
okay oscar price says jenny you would
love books by christopher buellman
i think you are the second person that
has uh recommended that author to me
great tomes of tara content okay i'm
gonna write that down because uh i'm
always looking for new [ __ ] i have all
my stuff what i'm what i'm starting to
do
the one that i'm putting up on monday
is
the uh the third
book in the messy man series
by uh chris sorensen
the lovely author that sent me the other
two books because i reviewed his first
book and then he sent me the other two
in the trilogy because he's awesome
uh so i reviewed that and then i'm
starting to do ones on because i kind of
ran out of print books and i can't
really afford to get any more right now
so
i'm gonna do like a bunch of kindle
unlimited ones because kindle unlimited
if you have a subscription to that
you can actually read a whole [ __ ] ton
of ebooks for free
um so i'm just kind of going through
there and picking ones that are
that i've been wanting to read oracle
says the worst book he's ever read was
battlefield earth
i saw the movie i can't i can see that
because
i haven't i haven't read battlefield
earth but i've read because i worked for
scientologists
i read a lot of elrond's quote-unquote
non-fiction
like a lot of his scientology like his
tech or whatever
um
and i know he was a pretty popular like
fiction writer and stuff but reading his
uh scientology adjacent stuff i'm just
kind of like this guy sounds like a
mental case i don't really know how his
fiction would come across
you know i don't i don't know i actually
liked the movie battlefield earth i
thought it was entertaining it's
terrible i thought it was entertaining i
thought i thought it was hilarious well
a lot of people think it's so terrible
that it's that it's hilarious yeah
[ __ ]
and the damn what they called them not
the cylons the [ __ ] uh [ __ ] i forgot
what they called them
uh cyclos there you go the cyclos yeah
and then they had to remember
yeah yeah
they were all interested in [ __ ] how
much profit they were going to make
looking all the little corporate [ __ ]
rules
it could have been a lot better i mean
there were there were some things about
it that
didn't really work all right
i think it could have been fixed
to me it just wasn't believable
well they did have the learning machines
that you could get in there and it would
suck that you know would blow [ __ ] into
your eyes and you could learn very
quickly
um
but they basically took a bunch of
caveman and before you know it they're
flying jets
that they found
you know what i mean in underground
storage that have been down there for
thousands of years or hundreds of years
that's not how jets work man you just
can't have a jet sit around for a
hundred years oh yeah we'll fly it too
well any kind of vehicle
that's not gonna work you can't deal
with a car no [ __ ] tires will be
rotten off just go look at an abandoned
car that's been in somebody's garage
yeah see how far you get with that
you're not going over there
it's just [ __ ] it's it's it's looks
like an abandoned car even though it's
been indoors they just
decay you know
and jets are
jet aircraft is far more
fragile you know they're just not really
made of anything lightweight materials
and
a lot of fuel injection [ __ ] and they're
just
no you're not going to really preserve
that for very long there they got to
work on those things constantly to keep
them running
so yeah it's like it's a machine yeah
they're set i mean ship breaks down yeah
everything does and machines don't like
to just sit there right yeah
zach says uh hey guys hey zach jenny
what's the worst book you've ever read
um
gosh
pro okay uh i'm sure i've read like a
lot of shitty ones um okay i can think
of two
i remember one i don't know if it was
the worst written book i've ever read
but it was the one that made me the
maddest
and that was son of rosemary by ira
levin
which was
the
sequel to rosemary's baby
um
i love ira 11. he wrote the stepford
wives he wrote a kiss before dying he's
an amazing amazing writer
however
this book
when i got to the end i threw
it across the room and i don't usually
do that i'm like really ivor really
that's where you're like you can't even
like oh my god it's just i'm not going
to spoil it in case you want to read it
but i don't know it just made me really
angry
more recently i think i talked about
this on my tomes of tara show because i
bought a book
at a used bookstore like a brand new
like pretty much brand new hardback and
i was like oh i've kind of heard of this
book um so i bought it it was only like
a couple of books and i said oh i can
review this for my show
and then i started reading it and i'm
like
this is some christian horror isn't it
and i was like oh
and then i was like oh well okay i'll
kind of like try to stick it out
but
i got like a little more way in there
and i was just kind of like no no i'm
just not wasting my time with this and
that was a monster by frank peretti
i was just kind of like
it's a bigfoot
story
yeah but it's essentially it's
creationist propaganda is what it is
and um i kind of saw that it was going
in that direction because i you know i
used to read a lot about creationism
like from you know the the atheist the
skeptic standpoint so i always i know
what their little tropes are and i know
what their little tricks are
so
a couple like little plot or a couple of
characters turn up in this book and i'm
just like oh this is going that way
didn't it and then like it went full on
that way like where this guy is just
like wait just but i don't even remember
if he said it's you know if if
evolution is true why are there still
monkeys you know what i mean but it was
like that level
of dumb
and i was just kind of like you know
what i just can't anymore with this so
i'm like so you're essentially making a
monster thing about bigfoot who
everybody thinks is a bad guy at first
but you're using bigfoot to like prove
creationism is true yeah i'm just like
no
absolutely not absolutely not
other people can read that if they want
to but
i'm just i'm not wasting my time with it
you know what i mean it's like there's
millions there's millions of good books
out there that i could be reading
uh you know a couple of which i one
actually one of which i read yesterday
but i'm not putting the review of it up
until probably the second week of
december yeah the whole monkeys are
still here argument
that's amazing when you think about it
well if the evolution is
real then why are the monkeys still here
that haven't always got me i was like
no we didn't come from those monkeys
dude
they don't understand
and then it's like and then they're all
smug about it like they're like
checkmate and i'm like do you not
understand how natural selection works
or how things are like branched off from
well they understand what common
ancestry means no they really don't and
it's just and it's funny to me that
they're that stupid but they don't like
realize that they're that stupid that
like something that transparently dumb
could like fool them well no one's
explained to them what common ancestry
means i have explained to them what
common ancestors i don't think they
wanna know yeah they don't really wanna
know they don't wanna know that's why
honestly like a long time ago because
like i said i used to be really into
um you know i read a lot of books about
evolution and
stuff like that and i read a lot of
books about because there was a time
when creationists were trying to like
shove their [ __ ] into like you know
public school science classes and stuff
and uh succeeded in a couple uh
instances
and so i was kind of like really
interested in that so i kept like
reading a lot about it and it's like i
kind of got to a point where i just
think
they want to believe creation and
creationism is true and they'll come out
and say well just you know give me proof
give me proof but you can give them
proof until you're blue in the [ __ ]
face
and they just won't
listen to it they'll come up with some
reason why that's not real or that's not
true or something they just want to
believe that and it's like i don't think
and i'm not saying that everybody that
they all can't be reached it's just that
i don't think they want to be reached i
think they have to like come to [ __ ] on
their own
arguing with them is not gonna
make them change their mind because they
don't want to
what's funny is that
is that [ __ ]
the bible the bible doesn't come out and
say that creationism is true either no
it doesn't no
it gives two different genesis stories
so
and the orders are different in both of
them
so uh
it's definitely not talking about
creationism
not in the way that they think of think
of it
well in the poetry it's definitely yeah
and the thing about it is that i mean
you can tell that the bible stories are
vague because look at all of the cr just
the christian denominations
that all believe something different but
can all point to something in scripture
that seems to back up
their beliefs so i was like well that
should tell you something right there
that you know that it's kind of vague
and can sort of be massaged
to say kind of whatever you wanted to
say
largely the you know the old testament
stuff from from genesis
it's basically sumerian
you know it's it's it's borrowing from
the epic of gilgamesh
and
it was never supposed to be a scientific
explanation it was just a [ __ ] poetic
explanation of how the gods made man and
how they made the earth
and then the great flood
that's that's
the people that read that were not
thinking in terms of like
well how did we evolve they're not
really thinking that way no they're you
know
so you're
you're forcing that literature to to
deliver on to cash a check that the
authors never intended to [ __ ]
yeah
that that was the authors were not
writing that check and you're trying to
cash in on it it's you that's well
that's why i kind of think a lot of
religion is kind of like you
come to a conclusion of what you want to
believe and then you'll like kind of
just pick and choose
what you want that seems to like back
that up you know what i'm saying yeah
i mean
people that are like creationists they
want to be create or they were raised to
be that and they don't know any better
those people you can kind of reach them
because if you actually like talk sense
to them sometimes they can come out of
it but people that want to believe that
there's really nothing you can tell them
that will convince them otherwise until
they kind of come to their own
realization that it doesn't make any
sense you know to me you read genesis
it's obviously a story
yeah it's a story there's nothing wrong
with that yeah it's a good story yeah
it's just a story they're not
they're not trying to to to impart to
you any kind of special scientific
knowledge about how
how man arose from the animals or that's
not not they weren't thinking that far
ahead i don't think no
they're just telling you a story
that's all
danny rolling ghostface says clyde
barker's book cabal is a good read yes
it is i haven't read it in a long time
uh honestly all of clyde barker [ __ ] is
really good i really really liked uh
weave world i really liked um
coldheart canyon
and his books of blood were amazing
honestly his books of blood
i read those when i was
[ __ ] man i couldn't have been that old
13 years old 14 years old
and
that i had read stephen king prior to
that and like other classics and stuff
but reading the books of blood that's
what made me want to be a horror writer
i'm like this dude is amazing i'm like
things like look at this [ __ ] he's come
up with it's so nasty and like so weird
and i loved it
but uh yeah all his books are good uh
damnation game is good too i have that
somewhere i have a bunch of his books
but uh
you know i haven't read cabal in a long
time though
um let's see oracle says i heard a great
way of thinking about it the bible is a
bunch of stories told by people trying
to recount history
but through the lens of what they
thought yeah kinda that's you know kinda
although
it's not history as you know it
most of it is an explanation of what
happened to certain gods
you see a lot of the gods that that they
were worshiping before the time before
judaism they've all been
kind of like um creatively rewritten and
re rebooted as
characters in the bible like for
instance aisha aisha means this hairy
guy
you know i mean with red hair and hair
on his back and he does some [ __ ]
but if you actually read the story
aisham is based upon one of the earlier
versions of one of their sun gods that's
what they're talking about
you know the sun rays and being red
and it's because
they want the authors are trying to
honor their ancestral gods and reboot a
new religion
so what do you do with the old gods you
just don't talk about them no you recast
them as angels or demigods or nephilim
and say oh yeah they existed but they're
not real gods they're just a nephilim
you know they're just angels that type
of stuff
so that's that's mostly what they're
doing and they're so they're not
rebooting
real history
they're rebooting the old religions
religious stories of the past
into something that
new people can accept
badass domain says would you guys do a
show about the book of revelation i
think we did did we if we didn't we
should
because that would be really fun yeah as
uh black house is good that's uh half
stephen king and half oh
don't you do it it's going red again no
it'll go red but it'll still hear us
because sometimes we can uh sometimes i
think we were having problems on
wednesday where it would be like it
would go okay
um yeah that's black house is the book
that's it's uh the sequel to the
talisman
and it's so it's half stephen king have
peter straub um
yeah so i actually i remember i didn't
love the talisman like i said i'm not
i've read a lot of his like stephen
king's more fantasy stuff like i read
the first dark tower red eyes of the
dragon but i like his more grounded
horror
um more than the fantasy i think
because i'm more a horror person i'm not
really a big fantasy person or a big
sci-fi person sometimes if it's like the
crossover is cool like i'll be into it
that but i usually love like just horror
[ __ ] and camp guy said uh read a lot of
king but not so much peter straub peter
straub's ghost story is excellent
um and i also really liked his book
julia which the haunting of julia was
based on the movie
which was called the which was called
full circle in the uk uh just like a
ghost story
and um
some of his other stuff like i have a
book of his like his short stories are
really good i have a short story
compilation called houses with outdoors
that's really good and
um what's the other one
what's that other one lost boy lost girl
is really good i just recently did a did
a review on the hellfire club which i
remember liking a lot but the second
time i read it i didn't like it as much
so peter straub is an excellent writer
but he's very hit or miss for me
um
you know some of his books i think are
amazing and then some of them just kind
of like
yeah you know what i mean so it's that
kind of thing
another reason why i'm saying that um
uh religion is not a retelling of
history is because if you look at the
the characters
they're retelling each other for
instance moses and jesus have the same
birth story same birth narrative they're
both running from a despotic tyrant
or their parents are running from a
despotic tyrant who's trying to wipe out
the firstborn or the newborn
children in the area so they have to be
taken to safety and then eventually they
become kings that's the same jesus and
jesus and moses have that same story um
you know hiding up in bethlehem or
whatever
uh [ __ ] then
born into manger because second herod
was trying to [ __ ] kill all the
firstborn well that was the same thing
that happened to moses it was a pharaoh
trying to kill off the firstborn and you
know its mother throws him in the damn
not a manger but a little basket and
[ __ ] goes down the nile and a
princess finds him and
he becomes ends up becoming
basically a king of the jews in the way
they both do
so no they're not retelling anything
historical they're rebooting gods jesus
is a reboot of moses a law giver
it's just that one was more jewish the
new one is more roman but it's the same
thing same
jesus is a retelling of moses
so that and neither one's history
neither one of those guys lived
well yeah there's stories there just you
know
that really [ __ ] a lot of people up
that [ __ ] me up for a while
i thought that jesus was a historical
person that they wrote
stories about and he began deified him
nah
no it's very unlikely it's a lot more on
it's a lot more likely that there never
was a jesus
that they have
rebooted moses as a holy man from the
past
because
there was some dif you know even
there
they're not even quite sure when we're
talking about there were some older
versions of these gospel stories
where he may have supposedly been born
about 60 years before they ended up
claiming that he was born around the
time of [ __ ] oh what's his name
pontius pilate pontius pilate putting
him to death so you know he's about 30
at that time so his birth date changed a
couple times in the history of
christianity and then after the fourth
century he was pretty much
put in the time of a pilot
but there's no way no he didn't live
during the time of pilot
[ __ ]
and whoever wrote those stories didn't
have a real good understanding
of history
uh uh and didn't really know the
geography much
you know
they're just making up a story about a
holy man from the past
down in judea you know
and then
back in the day
he was killed on the day of the passover
the more moses references
okay they executed them on passover and
then on the passover they do the jewish
uh blood ritual of scapegoating where
they let the evil the evil go go but the
good go the good lamb is sacrificed well
that's the same
letting [ __ ] uh barabbas go and then
sacrificing jesus and his blood washes
your sins away
that's the same that's
that's scapegoat ritual on passover
so no
no this didn't happen
no
yeah it's like fanfic it's fan
yeah it's magic yeah
it's jewish blood magic
it's what it is
they're not talking about a historical
event at all this is a spiritual
thing
like a play maybe they enacted this out
on stage at certain times
and
or you're supposed to imagine it and if
you accept that sacrifice your sin is
washed away that's the same as the
[ __ ]
scapegoat ritual you're in the thing
they're killing the goat they've left
they're killing the lamb they've let the
[ __ ] goat away you've chased that
over them over the hill and killed it
and then they kill the [ __ ] lamb and
its blood washes away your tribe's sins
if you see it you have to see it and
accept it
that's jesus that's what they're talking
about so no don't for one second think
that those were real people they were
not this is mythology just like
just like [ __ ] dionysus and just like
mercury and just like jupiter and other
roman gods that's exactly what it is
it's a jewish version of a roman god
because so many jews moved into rome in
that that period and they wanted they
didn't they didn't want to worship these
hillbilly religions and moses and [ __ ]
they wanted a new metropolitan roman
version of it and so they made up jesus
and jesus was one of god's
sons there was an angel of the angel of
jesus and angel jesus
and that was one of the 72 angels
during the time of genesis you know and
[ __ ]
israel chose yahweh and [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] worship molech and there was
another one named jesus
oh they know that there was one called
jesus so that's what they're talking
about the angel of jesus an angel jesus
he was an angel born through a woman
which wait a minute hold on what are you
talking about
born of woman they keep saying born of
woman well why would they keep saying
that because he wasn't born of a woman
you don't have to say that tom born of
woman
come on
jenny born of woman
nobody says that i don't know about you
but i was i i came out of a pumpkin
everybody's born of a woman
they're saying that because they're
they're claiming that jesus was born of
a woman or it would be like saying
gabriel the angel gabriel born of a
woman that's what they're saying
okay
that's my jesus rant yeah
it was a rant it's a rant i think his
educational rant yeah just a different
way of looking at it you're looking at
it through modernized you're not looking
at it through the eyes that they had in
the third second third fourth century
they didn't see it the same way you did
it wasn't a fully formed religion back
then
john smith says i love poppy z bright as
a horror author i do as well uh they're
yeah not writing anymore um they're
trans they go by billy martin now
um
but yeah lost souls was great uh
exquisite corpse is great really [ __ ]
up that was actually one of the most
[ __ ] up books i ever read so [ __ ]
gory
um
liquor which was a later one which
actually wasn't horror exactly
but
yeah it's like
that was one of the first times that i
actually read some stuff
you know it was poppy z bright caitlyn
kiernan
people like that they were actually
writing about the goth scene back then
like in new orleans and stuff and you
didn't really
there wasn't a lot of that in mainstream
fiction so i think lost souls was the
first book that i read like that and i'm
like holy [ __ ] crap this is just like
you know
this is just like people i know
it was like really weird camp guy then
says best king short stories my pretty
pony dedication donovan's cadillac and
apt pupil yeah apt pupil is great i
honest i really really like i mean i
like a lot of stephen king's novels too
but he doesn't get enough credit for his
short fiction i don't think i mean i
read
um what the [ __ ] night shift that one
book that has it has quitters inc and it
has uh
it has like a whole bunch of his kind of
famous short stories in it and i read
that so many times that the [ __ ]
cover fell off i mean those books those
stories were like so good
strawdog 78 says i prefer his bachmann
books like the long walk yeah one of my
favorite books of all time that is so
[ __ ] great honestly the bachmann
books are like really really good that's
the one that had um what was the movie
we were just talking about the uh the
running man that was the one that had
the running man in it and rage
which
you know that that's so that was kind of
like a prescient wasn't it because that
was kind of like about a school shooter
and he wrote that like way back in the
old days
peggy peggy hi jenny and tom how do you
like your new house
happy american thanksgiving greetings
from canada yeah because canada y'all's
thanksgiving is in october yeah you have
to buy it
yeah yeah i'll buy it i'm gonna buy it
we're just gonna buy it because we want
to like paint it
paint it and i don't want to lose equity
in a damn house
yeah because i'll be here for at least a
couple years so
yeah because i might as well buy
it's
it
it's a nice place this is a nice
neighborhood yeah nice and quiet
most of the time
other than that one guy with his loud
stereo yeah
and earlier today when you were gone
i heard some i heard gunshots yeah but
that's all i mean it's rural around here
so it's not like yeah the law is is that
you can shoot as long as you have one
acre on which to shoot
so we're we're not in what we're not
what's called a city limit
per se we're we're in we're you know
we're in
on the land so you can shoot here
this whole [ __ ] garden this hole
around the base of this whole house
where there's these little gardens that
this guy had made
it's instead of wood chips it's all
[ __ ]
five five six and nine millimeter brass
they were in here [ __ ] shooting all
the time but i don't know they were just
dumping their brass out so if you're a
reloader you can come here and pick all
this up template tumble it all and
reload it
might do it who knows
yeah because we don't have equation we
have what three quarters of an acre
about that yeah i think it's three
quarters of an acre this long it's a
corner if you have an acre you can shoot
but you gotta have a backstop and
everything you know but that's easy to
build
yeah it's like well and the thing about
it is that we don't really have anything
i mean it's three quarters of an acre
which sounds like a lot and it's a big
lot but there's still like houses
there's a little house right there and
there's a house behind us there's a
house across the street and there's
nothing
i mean it's open there's nothing really
in the way we don't have like any
privacy hedges or anything like that
which eventually we'll get but
it's weird you know i looked at the
[ __ ] sidewinder the other day when i
was working out and stuff like and i
guess there were
three or four people i don't know if it
was girl look there's like a mixture of
girls and guys driving the damn golf
carts
it had lights on the golf carts and
they're obviously drinking
drinking driving the golf cart at night
through the [ __ ]
well yeah not much else to do around
here
back again they're looking and they're
waving
maybe
drinking all the drinking trouble
drinking and driving on the golf carts i
mean i wouldn't i wouldn't normally uh
be down with that but there's really not
hardly any traffic around here this is
the country there's like nothing around
here i mean there's houses but it's not
like you know it's not fast traffic no
it's like everybody's neighbors here
they don't care if you're drinking and
driving here in a golf cart in a golf
cart yeah because there's kind of like
well down that other street there's like
a lake and you can go fishing and
there's like a golf
course and all that other kind of [ __ ]
yeah
dermot says bram stoker's dracula
original victorian format was a tough
read for me too archaic
i didn't have too much trouble with
dracula i do like a lot of victorian
fiction but for sure some of them are
way harder to follow than other ones
depends on the writer you know what's
interesting i didn't really have and i
don't remember if i talked about this
when i was talking about dan simmons
book druid when i reviewed it
um but
i found
wilkie collins who was also a victorian
writer he usually wrote like mystery
type stuff like he wrote the woman in
white and the moonstone
um i found those pretty easy to get
through i don't know if that's just me
or
or his diction was a lot more modern
than other people at the time because
honestly i don't have too much problem i
like a lot of that victorian era like
gothic literature and stuff but some
writers were kind of like a little more
i don't know prolix a little more
verbose
uh and some of them were a little more
you know a little more stripped down
like and it seemed a little more modern
to me graham says i built my own
backstop out of two by fours and filled
it with compressed hay from tractor
supply yeah
i was looking at that brass down there
to the date i was thinking about
reloading again
i don't have any of my reloading
supplies anymore they're all my dad's
house he's when he passes baby i'll
inherit it we'll see
i mean uh
probably you know i have to go down here
and pick it up unless he's giving it
away to some of his friends
but um
yeah i haven't reloaded in a long time
used to love reloading you'd get [ __ ]
lost in that [ __ ]
used to a low 45 9 millimeter i used to
[ __ ] reload 32 acp
you'd be like what people don't realize
how expensive 32 acp was
you know it was more expensive than nine
millimeter at the time and i had a colt
03 pocket hammerless that was just a
[ __ ] tag driver and it was like 95
quality it was like a show
showpiece man and it was from a 1930s
manufacturer
and that thing was so [ __ ] sweet i
used to load up 32 acp lead semi-wad
cutters and you could just put them all
in one single [ __ ] hole
and that was just a factory gun the
factory [ __ ] cult pocket pistol from
the 30s just something they used to just
pump them out and they were better than
[ __ ] any modern target pistol they
were beautiful
just the perfect size little narrow slim
skinny little
32 and
a little pop gun
they were kind of like the nine
millimeters of the day
just
handy little things
basically love reloaded and it was kind
of relaxing
remember one time i loaded up about a
thousand rounds of 45 all that [ __ ]
wed and [ __ ] and [ __ ] up i forgot i
had a whole loading block full of
[ __ ]
primed brass and i was going through and
i was charging them all with them
[ __ ] powder measure and i forgot to
charge one of the [ __ ] loading blocks
i had 50 rounds of [ __ ] dummy rounds
just with [ __ ] primers in them and
mixed in with damn near a thousand
rounds of [ __ ] 45 so you couldn't
shoot it out you couldn't throw it away
you had to shoot it
[ __ ] man every out of that thousand
rounds i had to [ __ ] hit those
[ __ ] 50 rounds
that were dead and they would [ __ ]
throw the bullet [ __ ] down in through
past the chamber
a lot of times you detect it sometimes
you wouldn't you just go click and you
go what the [ __ ] pull the [ __ ] slide
in the rear
you'd eject the empty case and you'd
look in there and the bullet would be
wedged right in the [ __ ] about an
inch down the barrel [ __ ] panty ass
but uh
yeah those are the days man we've got to
get back into that [ __ ]
thank you camp guy
sent us a super chat love the podcast
perfect for me like walking into a bar
and hanging with my buddies yeah that's
good that's kind of what we would do
that's kind of what we wanted
yeah john smith said yep i got into pop
easy bright thinking he was going to be
like anne rice i was wrong yeah really
not like anne rice
i mean the only thing that's similar is
like the new orleans setting
other than that like all poppy z bride
stuff is like super super scuzzy and
honestly
if i rem if i'm remembering it correctly
exquisite corpse
was based on
loosely based on jeffrey dahmer
and somebody else so there was like a
lot of really gross like so it's almost
like a weird
love story kind of between like two
serial killer cannibals and it was like
really [ __ ] up it was one of the most
messed up things i ever read it was like
so so disgusting and that's like saying
something coming from me
um yeah camp guy says all the king's
short stories are great
they're about three or four full-size
books of just short stories yeah
honestly like i said i just
i don't know i just i feel like a lot of
people talk about his novels which are
also good but his short stories are
saying so good
i mean i don't know graham i might do
something like that but i don't know
about the backdrop i think i'm gonna do
something kind of
spiritual with some lights and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] oh we'll see we'll see i don't
know
i don't know if i
don't want it to be i don't want it to
be [ __ ] um
focused on one subject my channel my my
show i want it to be
a good
general channel so i have a lot of cool
[ __ ] on it
we'll see
uh mr roboto shows up and says hi to
everybody so hi mr robotto now that
thanks killing is over tom jenny you
ready for a black christmas
oh yeah absolutely we already put our uh
christmas lights out
which we do like the lazy christmas
lights which are just like the
projection ones
we have what do we even have is it like
is it snowflakes uh no our peppermint
things one of them is a green and red
laser display looks like it just looks
like snowflakes and the other ones
that's what i said the other one is a
big um
uh we call it a projection of cartoon
santa claus face oh santa claus face
i think snowflakes moving around i think
i thought we had something that was like
little peppermint wheels or something
we need to get some more of those
we only have two of them
and it's kind of like
i mean the front of the house is kind of
big so we need to kind of get a few more
we could use to get another one we can
get another one
everybody already put everybody put
their christmas decorations out already
like last week they're like way ahead i
need to get a dab gopro so i can hook it
up to my helmet i'll ride through here
and we'll put it on the show
yeah you could well you could um you
could glue my phone to your helmet
i'll get a decent gopro
yeah i don't you know you could probably
get one for not about 100 bucks you
should have got one today on black
friday
yeah you can get one oh you can wait
till cyber monday yeah where they're
supposed to have all the deals online i
got a lot of [ __ ] we gotta [ __ ] buy
over the next couple months though [ __ ]
man and i am so broke yeah oh my god
it's like not even funny it's like
i spent nearly 40 bucks i think just on
[ __ ] bar tab today with including the
tip so
oh [ __ ] yeah i have money though but
not me
just kind of one drink went into the
next i realized those things were
[ __ ] seven dollars a drink you know
well that's pretty standard i mean for
for a mixed drink yeah you know yeah
for is that a single or a double it's a
single oh yeah that's a well yeah that's
about right most bars charts
they were
patron
patron [ __ ] um
sunrises
oh okay yeah
oscar perez talking about exquisite
corpses vile all shock value no
substance yeah it's uh not for the
squeamish that's for sure i haven't i
have it um i haven't read it in a long
time i remember reading it a long time
ago and being like man this is
this is uh [ __ ] up it's not 80 to 80
degrees in florida right now it's uh
70 what is it maybe 70 71. honestly the
last few days like it was it's been cool
like one day it was in the 50s which was
kind of nice and we had the windows open
yeah pookie was very excited yeah she's
like whoa she was like sitting on the
thing looking out the screen yeah like
wow and there was like a little breeze
and everything
um
but it's mostly in the 70s so yeah you
could totally get away with wearing
shorts though
um let's see oh camp guy also brings up
a rose for emily that is a great
great short story if you've never read
that yeah it's online except go read it
if you're into like southern gothic
stuff
um
yeah faulkner honestly anything like
that i'm a big fan of like flannery
o'connor as well so
uh read some of her stuff as well
because that's like really kick-ass
uh mr roboto says doesn't that display
drive cats crazy no they love it
honestly we have like all these colored
lights in here like you can see them
like behind there and i just mostly just
leave these on all the time because it's
painted ass to like turn them off and on
yeah and sometimes if you turn them off
they turn on and it's like a different
color it's doing some crazy [ __ ] we have
a little sunburst that [ __ ] shine up
on the walls at night you know green and
light blue and and they love that [ __ ]
if you put up a new one
pookie will go over and sit and sit down
next to it and just like look at it like
bathe in the light
and the uh
we're hitting the house with these laser
beams
through the main
above the main door there's a big window
and it some of the lasers come in and
they
they hit the staircase and up on the
ceilings and
cookie sits up there and just looks at
them you know yay they know they know
what holiday lights are
yeah she doesn't really try to like
she's really trying to like jump on them
although we did used to have a laser
pointer yeah she'd run after that and
she'd run after that but the ones in the
house i guess she's so used to us having
colored lights like colored lights on
all the time that she's just kind of
like oh it's another one of these and
i'm not entirely sure
how um
how cat's vision like
perceives that yeah like can they see it
is it all white to them is it all gray
to them i don't really know i think they
see that that they move
yeah they do see in color
yeah i thought they did yeah i mean i
know that
down she'll get right into a light beam
and lay down in it yeah she just kind of
like likes to yeah kind of sit there
with like little green light washing
over a little blue light yeah
she's the weirdest cat ever yeah
it's like a splashing on her yeah
i don't know why she likes it so much
it's not warm or anything so i don't
really know she just thinks it's neat
yeah um
oscar prize says jenny reed the wide
carnivorous sky by john langham author
of the fisherman i've seen a lot of
people recommend the fishermen but i
haven't gotten around to reading any
john lagang yet
um but i will i promise honestly like i
said i've been reading a lot of stuff on
what do you call it kindle unlimited
and the last two that i read
i really really liked like i did reviews
for them which i recorded already but
they won't go up until later like the
first couple weeks of december
but
one of them that i read was called
doo doo doo what was it called autumn
bleeds into winter and that was really
really good and then um i read
the whisper man which was like a
thriller
and that was also
excellent so i did reviews of both of
those
uh midwest outlaw 420 says we need a
modern non-musical phantom of the opera
and creature from the black lagoon
honestly
i kind of feel like the poor creature
from the black lagoon doesn't get any
love man
look at all of the movies they made
about dracula and frankenstein's monster
and the mommy and stuff like that but
like creature from black lagoon just me
and wolf man the gill man yeah they
don't do really much with the gill man
the gilman is so cool
i mean honestly the last thing you know
they did monster squad
which i reviewed like halloween week
and the gill man in that one is like
really kick-ass he like looks really
good but even in that movie like the
gill man's only he's barely in it
even though he has the best makeup in
the movie i mean he looks the coolest
of all the mommy's cool too but the gill
man looks the best but he's like in it
the least which is kind of a shame it
could be young
oh sorry are we boring you know
i'm worried about that turkey down there
too why are you worried about it because
i'm gonna have to cut that turkey up
half of it
how much of it's left
half
half half
yeah
i just uh yeah i had a turkey sandwich
for lunch today yeah
turkey sandwich it was really good might
have another one after the show because
you ate before the show but i didn't eat
well i had i had a piece a little piece
of pumpkin bread before the show because
i didn't want myself so completely empty
we got so much stuff to eat i couldn't
believe
well because you've been down there
farting around for like three days yeah
just cooking yeah and doing stuff yeah
and i didn't really know what you were
doing
so when it was all like laid out
yesterday i was like holy [ __ ] crap
it's like this huge [ __ ] turkey had
like cream corn you had [ __ ] yeah
two different stuffings a bunch of
different gravies you had like green
bean casserole
you had uh mashed potatoes your beets
you had two different kinds of pies two
different kind of pizzas
you had like sweet potatoes and pecans
in them i didn't like how those turned
out
and it was just it was so much stuff i
haven't even had i haven't had any of
the pie yet i haven't even eaten i
couldn't yesterday i ate one plate and
then i was like okay i'll eat a tiny bit
more because i just wanted some more
turkey then i was like okay uh and then
like i couldn't like eat anymore
and
then i just went and kind of laid down
and watched some mst and write a book
for a while
and then later you know later i had a
little bit more but man my stomach was
really hurting this morning
it really was but yeah i haven't had any
pie i mean you pumpkin pie we haven't i
don't think we've cut the pumpkin pie
yet have we oh
we cut the pecan pie
i had a piece of that but i had a piece
of that like before thanksgiving oh [ __ ]
you got the lights on in it what are you
doing i would want to turn the fan well
you can turn the light on and then turn
the light off in the middle
that's kind of what you're doing yeah i
mean yeah
how
hot it is for me
yeah you and all your problems yeah
like a fan
grant there's hammer to build a fire is
a great story yeah that's jack london
i remember that one i remember we read
that one in school
poor bastard has one match finally gets
a fire going at a pine tree then stands
up and excitement bumps a branch and the
snow falls on this fire
nature says [ __ ] you that's what happens
uh yeah midwest outlaw 420 says the new
wolf man from 2010 was shite um
wait which one did i see that
was that the one with benit with uh
beniccio del toro
or was that no that was earlier than
that it had to have been
i remember seeing a wolfman movie with
benicio del toro in it who i was like oh
that's good casting he's very wolf manny
in a foxy kind of way
and i remember seeing that in the
theater but i kind of feel like that one
was earlier
[ __ ] man
i don't know
yeah you said okay he said yeah that was
that one all right for some reason i
thought that one was earlier
huh
i remember it being okay but i don't
remember hardly anything about it now
that i'm thinking about it you know what
i'm saying
um so i need to go to the bathroom so
you should probably you should probably
talk i don't know why you're having such
a hard time talking today i'm having a
hard time talking yeah let me just have
a hard time talking well because you're
just like sitting there like you're no
because you keep talking i wanted to
interrupt you
see that's the thing
if i interrupt her then she's like why
you're interrupting me i'm just gonna
let her talk
you know
that's how women are you can't win
yeah tom's not drinking we talk about
man i've been drinking all day
i was [ __ ] drinking at the [ __ ]
bar
hmm
okay tammy says uh
he said i tried the brazilian cream cord
from the cookbook and everyone loved it
yeah i told you
i told you it's a very different kind of
cream corn isn't it
that's real cream corn it's not you
american cream corn is when you just
take corn and you just kind of
puree it a little bit nah
nah brazilians will take a whole kernel
corn
and add a cream sauce to it
it's it's [ __ ] it's best it's the
best it's far superior
to american cream corn i mean tell me
more about that tammy what'd they say
about it
i'm happy to hear that i [ __ ] love it
yeah patrons the best tequila i was
that's why i was drinking patron patron
silver
that's good [ __ ]
tammy said that uh that she made the
brazilian cream style corn from the
cookbook uh
and everybody loved it
yeah we made it he made that too
yeah it's easy to make too but it's just
it's just [ __ ] fantastic i mean it's
mostly like cream with some corn in it
but well no it's it's mostly
it's mostly corn it's mostly corn yeah i
had a bunch of that for lunch today it
was really good
it's kind of got it's kind of sweet
yeah
yeah
i mean we make that kind of like every
year it's what i don't know it's
it's kind of like i feel like cream corn
at least from a traditional american
point of view is kind of a weird
thanksgiving side dish yeah
but not when you see my cream corn yeah
but
he makes it every year just just
google brazilian cream style
google brazilian cream corn they call it
they call it [ __ ] um
creme de milieu
cream corn
creamy demeanor
camp guy said thanksgiving reminds me
my grandmother's house and her
dishwasher you could move it around in
the kitchen and hooked it up to the
kitchen sink i remember those i think
yeah i remember i don't i didn't know
anybody that had one but i remember they
were all old school yeah that was old
school [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] funny to think about
jinx says mexico tequila has a worm at
the bottom you eat it and they finish
okay nah nah you got that wrong bro
that is actually a [ __ ] um a
misunderstanding
the stuff that had a warm worm in the
bottom of it
was one of the brands of mexican mezcal
but not all mezcal had that
um tequila originally never had that
until white people started [ __ ]
asking for it and the mexicans like
wherever the tequila all right here take
it
but no [ __ ] work dumbass yeah that
never that was that's some dumb ass
[ __ ]
uh the worm was out of a particular
brand of mezcal
and mezcal has nothing to do with
tequila
it's more like a beer
i just i could never get into tequila
yeah i don't mind the odd sunrise every
now and then depending on what kind of
tequila it is
but i don't know i have to be in the
right mood
tequila's not made out of mezcal it's
made out of agave
mezcal's made out of mescal these
like a cactus
fermented cactus type thing
dj maniac says good thing white people
didn't start asking for human toes like
that one bar up in canada
i bought it in virginia thanks for the
clarification i believed it for years
yeah they they
that you can find tequila with a worm in
it but that's for gringos man
that's tourist [ __ ]
well timmy that seems like a really good
that seems like a really good troll yeah
they're trolling you
it's just kind of like let's make them
think that this is the authentic mexican
experience yeah you have to eat the worm
when you get to the bottom right
they're trolling dumbass white people
yeah
that would be super fun i think that
happened
i think that happened back in the 70s
when you had a lot of white people just
[ __ ] going from
southern california
into uh tijuana back in the 70s
they would do this [ __ ] on a lark like
let's go to tijuana it's like a joke you
know i mean everyone will [ __ ] watch
a donkey show and get drunk or some [ __ ]
yeah like i said watch some chick like
shoot ping-pong balls at her yeah you
know we'll spend twenty dollars it'll be
great
and i i think somebody ran across mezcal
and saw that
and mistook it for tequila
got him confused
conflated the two
and it started a big [ __ ]
rumor up in up in
southern california that tequila had a
worm in it
it never had a wire minute you you don't
believe me check check google you'll see
the whole tequila and the worm thing is
[ __ ]
and it's funny because that's really
kind of cemented in the
culture at this point isn't it
now
some people reported that you could find
after all that [ __ ]
that you could start finding
bottles of tequila with the worm in it
but that's mexicans making that [ __ ] put
a worm in the bottom man sell to that
gringo
let's see if he'll eat it yeah yeah
then for all you know they might have
said well let's make a hundred dollar
version of that make a high-class
version to eat that
because you know
companies will go where the market
demand is well yeah a gringo would
[ __ ] buy that [ __ ] a mexican wouldn't
that's like what
give me some alagro yeah they just took
a drink
they'll mix silver
but you know
silver tequila is the mexican version of
of vodka
they'll mix that
but gold or reposado they don't mix that
you can but yeah that's the good [ __ ]
that's like the aged stuff yeah that's
like scotch to them yeah they don't mix
that
they're definitely gonna put a worm in
it
yeah why would you want to do that yeah
you know what's funny i had a friend
this was years ago uh who went to mexico
probably tijuana and came back and
brought me
a tequila flavored lollipop
that for some reason had a scorpion
suspended in it yeah
and in a way i was like one i'm not
gonna eat this and two
what like why would you do that to the
poor scorpion you could eat a scorpions
like today i'm not going to eat
scorpion candies and [ __ ] but i'm just
like to me it just seemed kind of mean i
was kind of i was kind of like oh
yeah poor guy yeah
he's like in a [ __ ] lollipop now
that's like really sad
it's sold though somebody bought it well
yeah she did because she gave it to me
you're probably not never meant to eat
it it's probably just
well yeah it's just one of those things
that's like a gag you know like a gag
gift i mean there's a bunch of stuff
that you can buy
that's purportedly food yeah but really
you're not supposed to eat it we were in
fye the other day last time we went to
the movies and it was we got there
really early because like i said our
theater is at the altamonte mall
so we went across to the mall and we
were in the food court and sometimes if
we have time to kill for the movie we'll
go in fye because it's right there by
the food court
and they have this whole section
of they have like a [ __ ] ton of like
japanese snacks they have like pocky and
they have all that kind of stuff
in there and they had
okay what the [ __ ] was it it was
was it gummies i kind of feel like it
was gummies but it was this big huge box
and it looked like a bento box like it
had all the kind of like sushi and all
this other stuff but it was all like
gummy candy yeah and it's like i almost
see this is this is what i'm saying it's
like i almost wanted to buy it even
though i don't even like gummy candy and
i you know i wouldn't have eaten it i
just because i just thought it was so
neat and it like looked really cool yeah
you know what i mean
i like things that look like other
things does that make any sense bee's
nest goes to goes to mexico all the time
all right he uh he works over there
and he says he still sees
he that they still sell the [ __ ] worm
and the bottle of tequila over there he
says he sees it he says i'll send you a
picture of it because i know they do but
that's
go on the internet and go [ __ ] do the
research and you'll find out
that is not a mexican i think that's
evidently a gringo thing
they're they're [ __ ] they did that to
sell it to [ __ ] gregos
it didn't it
it didn't have a worm in it until
[ __ ] people from california started
to ask for it because they believed it
should have been in there
but see this is my suspicion it's not
about
every culture that has some like super
super gross ass food yeah you know what
i mean i always suspect that no one
that's actually native to that culture
would ever eat that in a million years
yeah but they always like just play it
up because then when tourists come they
can make them eat it like you're not
like a real whoever like a finnish
person or whatever until you eat this
disgusting ass [ __ ] and they're just
like
we would never read that
it's not going to [ __ ] go on to
[ __ ]
ireland and kissing the [ __ ] blarney
stone blarney means [ __ ] okay
all right kiss the barney stone and
they're pissing on the blarney storm
stone at night
going down there and you're kissing the
blarney stone they were pissing on it
even if people weren't pissing on it can
you imagine all the [ __ ] microbes on
that [ __ ] from all those people's
[ __ ] gross ass mouths on there no
thank you
no thank you
just saying i don't even let i don't
even i don't even let tom use my
toothbrush so i'm not gonna let go
[ __ ]
lick some stone that's had all these
[ __ ] strangers lips on it disgusting
kissing the blarney stone
come down here to [ __ ] florida come
kiss the [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god yeah yeah
that's a genius well we have to think of
like some other name for [ __ ] that
still sounds kind of like [ __ ] but
it's not [ __ ]
no that's too obvious too obviously
it's
they're like what it tastes like blown
air
oh my god
that would be so [ __ ] funny
yeah i'm gonna have to think of this i
have to think of this they're they're
irish man of course they're gonna do it
these [ __ ]
tourists coming up they're going there
i'm gonna come see my ancestors man all
your ancestors are dead all right
[ __ ]
you show up there and
they're gonna [ __ ] tell you a
whole long story of blarney give you a
whole [ __ ] a whole 10 gallon hat full
of blarney and then
fool you into kissing this stone that
somebody was pissing on the [ __ ] day
before yeah they're always like
they're laughing yeah go ahead and pay
me some money for the tour yeah okay
they're like look at they paid me for
the privilege yeah
yeah
you know i mean you can see why they do
that of course nobody likes tourists
yeah and i'm not saying that like nobody
should go anywhere ever that they're not
from it's just that there's a certain
there's people that are just like
traveling and then there's people that
are like tourists yeah and there's a
difference between those two types of
people
so you know
like i said i grew up in daytona beach
i've had my fair share of
tourists and too bad we didn't really
have anything in daytona that we could
sort of uh you know
[ __ ] yeah they made him pay money to
even kiss the stone yeah they're
honestly they're not going to let people
do that for free yeah they're irish man
look i i can't share a [ __ ] common
ancestry with them they're gonna [ __ ]
tell you a bunch of [ __ ] and get
some money out of you
and then make you do something it's like
eating armadillo eat that armadillo
if you do you really want to be southern
eat that [ __ ] you don't do i've never
eaten an orbital though i would not eat
unless i was unless it was like a
post-apocalyptic my uncle would my uncle
eat him and i was just like dude
it's like come on you realize it's the
21st century yeah right i mean we have
actual food they were eating that [ __ ]
in the 60s and 70s and so he's still
eating [ __ ] it's all kinds of [ __ ]
funny [ __ ]
my [ __ ] southern [ __ ] cajun
relatives would eat
[ __ ]
it was a stuffed redfish that was what
uncle punch would [ __ ] eat i called
him uncle punch he's not my real uncle
it's just that dudes that your dad grew
up with are automatically your uncle
well yeah that's what well it was too
complicated when you were a kid to say
well it's just like your dad's friend
right now he's not related right
uncle ponch would eat [ __ ] stuffed
redfish and he was catching redfish
before they would blacken redfish and
make him [ __ ] famous
you could catch a redfish in mississippi
and louisiana in that area it would be
considered kind of like a garbage fish
like what is that thing it's a redfish
what the [ __ ] is a redfish they don't
have red fish in the restaurant so well
not yet well he was right
eventually they had [ __ ] redfish
blackened red fish and blackened the
catfish
that's [ __ ] caging as [ __ ]
even though paul perdom and [ __ ] it's
not as cajun as you think it is but
he would take a red fish and make
stuffing
kind of like
well it's made out of crackers but it
was kind of like
stuffing for for crab you know like we
mixed stuff crab yeah it was like that
not gonna lie i'd eat the idea yeah hey
chris he'd take he'd take stuffing for
like like make a stuffed crab
and he'd have a redfish in there just
totally uh
uh deboned and
flaky fish in it and make [ __ ]
redfish stuffing and then he'd take that
stuff and stuff it inside of another
redfish that had been
not
like a turducken but it's like
it's like a tur red fish
[Music]
so he'd stuff these redfish and [ __ ]
with it
he'd deep fry him and [ __ ]
that's probably good what are you
laughing at that for it was good he deep
fried did he come out that sounds
delicious like a [ __ ] football
anything wrong with that and you have
these two things that look like two
footballs on a second plate
with his feet up like that [ __ ]
flip-flops
watching tv this is like back in the
early 80s and [ __ ] you know
and he'd [ __ ] pour a whole bunch of
uh um
cocktail sauce you know you take yeah
that sounds good ketchup
you need to make me that yeah ketchup
with horseradish in it a little bit of
lemon and he'd be pouring that on
oh man oh man that's like it's delicious
oh man it's just funny you know just
fine
stuffed cat what is that uncle punched
up red fish
they all sound like chips
no i can't i'm gonna do this dongle
punch
that's more like my dad yeah
it's a stuffed red fish
hell yeah
oh yeah stuffed red fish you never heard
of a stuffed redfish okay and you know
who uncle poncha looked like he looked
just like aj he looks just like alex
jones that's what uncle punch looked
like except he was bald well alex shows
the ball though down too
but he had like a big bald spot that's
that's what uncle punch looked like it's
just [ __ ] funny
fishing in the gulf of mexico with it
with my dad [ __ ] the boat was [ __ ]
going up and down i was about [ __ ] 13
13 or 14 i was getting sick as [ __ ] and
i started throwing up over the side of
the [ __ ] boat his
his cute ass daughter was with me too
she was [ __ ] getting sick too
she was probably about 16. i was
probably about 13. i was [ __ ]
throwing up over the side of the boat
[ __ ] uncle punch goes here here you
go little tommy
[ __ ] eat you another bar there's
another butters thing and i go and
make you feel better it'll feel better
coming back up
so i was sitting there eating it
thinking ahead man i got seasick
yeah yeah
i don't remember getting seasick i
haven't been out i haven't been out on a
[ __ ] ton of boats but i don't remember
[ __ ] going up and down yeah
doing it for hours
we're getting to where the good fish are
yeah yeah yeah stop puking on my boat
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] funny but yeah
that stuff redfish that that actually
sounds uh delightful that sounds like
you could like elevate that [ __ ] you
could like charge it you could charge
like hundreds of dollars then it was
just funny looking because you know he
put every bit of stuffing he could
probably possibly [ __ ] fit in well
why not it was the [ __ ] it was
okay as stuff
yeah
[ __ ] redfish is normally about that
thick laying on its side this [ __ ] was
like that it was literally the size of
an american [ __ ] football that's
great and it was [ __ ] all exposed
[ __ ]
all exposed [ __ ] stuffing on the
bottom of it it was barely contained i
was like why did you just pull that out
eat that big old ball of [ __ ]
stuff and just let him do what he wants
to do yeah just let him do it
yeah that sounds really good yeah
[ __ ] bread beezness says nastiest
[ __ ] i tried was balut egg yeah i've
heard those are pretty gross those are
like rotten eggs essentially yeah and
yeah that's not i i don't know like some
of the things i guess some of the things
if it's culturally you grew up eating it
as nasty as it is um you know you'd get
used to it you get a taste for it but
some stuff it's just like
you know like a durian fruit it's just
it smells like a corpse
uh so one why would anybody have even
like had the idea to eat it in the first
place because they're like you know
nature says if it smells like a dead
thing like a dead person
maybe don't eat that it's like a red
flag um and i feel like it it doesn't
taste good enough to justify getting
past the smell
it's almost kind of i don't really like
food that's just like a dare
you know what i mean yeah honestly if a
food smells like a corpse there's no way
that it could taste good enough
to justify me getting past that smell
yeah there's just no way
uh dj maniac says elsa says hi hi elsa
she wants to borrow some of your
florinian humidity oh she's welcome to
it yeah uh take all of it actually you
can have all of it
all all year
oscar perez has jenny have you seen
naked from 1993 i have indeed many many
times starring david thulis extremely
heavy british accents yeah that's a mike
lee movie and i'm actually really a
massive fan of mike lee movies uh naked
probably my second favorite i think my
first favorite is probably life is sweet
which is more of a comedy naked was very
depressing but it was also really really
good but uh yeah mike lee made some like
amazing movies so if you guys haven't
seen them vera drake was also really
good
poor cow was good he made like a [ __ ]
ton of good ones um
somebody's asking if we're gonna see
the resident evil movie we'll probably
get around to it
i kind of want to see the ghostbusters
one i want to see nightmare alley but
that doesn't start for another couple
weeks
so maybe we'll see it like i said i'm
not rolling up on the resident evil like
i know
essentially what the story is but you
know
grant there's hammer says
you can buy
frozen raccoon in detroit
at a place called eastern market
eyeballs still in the head that's
ridiculous lots of southern black folk
moved here to work in factories but
still eat mississippi dishes
how can you eat a raccoon they're so
cute
yeah the funny thing about raccoon is
that people ate raccoons at it kind of
like necessity
um
i've only heard of a few people that
actually ate them and they're not very
good
probably be about like eating [ __ ]
cat
there's not much meat there
it would be tough
um just wouldn't be that good
there's other things to eat in
mississippi
if i mean it's like nowadays there's
really not much excuse yeah there are
cute little things and uh you know it'd
be like eating a cat i wouldn't do it no
so where are they getting these raccoons
from the pound are they [ __ ] farming
them maybe they're farming them
because it would be illegal you can't
you can't sell game meat unless it's
something real exotic and you've got
licenses to do it but in the us you
mostly cannot sell game meat
it's against the law unless you have a
you need a commercial license for it
well yeah because it doesn't go through
like all the ch they you know they can't
really say whether it's full of
parasites or whatever well it's not just
that they don't want people going out
there hunting hunting food and selling
to [ __ ] grocery stores yeah well
you don't kill out whole populations of
animals yeah i mean it's understandable
you're right
you wanted to go through the chain they
wanted to go through the food supplies
yeah
um oscar perez says what's a good food
that smells bad but tastes good
cheese
yeah i smell some blue cheese and then
you go tell me
yeah i guess well i'm not a huge fan of
blue cheese so
yeah i'm gonna like i love cheeses of
all kinds but usually the cheeses i like
are not the real strong smelling ones
but yeah that's probably like the best
they do some of them do kind of smell
like feet yeah
but they're still kind of good blue
cheese is okay i could take it or leave
it it's i'm not a big fan i think smith
i think fish smells horrible raw
when it's cooked it's okay
honestly the smell of fish doesn't
bother me i hate it don't like it it
doesn't bother me at all
i don't know maybe because like i said
maybe because i grew up on the coast
yeah so do not like this i was at the
beach all the time so it was always kind
of like a fishy smell around all the
time because like the ocean was right
there going to fish markets and i'm like
yeah this place smells bad
i don't really like how it smells
just not used to it
yeah
shellfish i like it you know i just
don't like the smell of it yeah
yeah it doesn't really bother me i don't
like you know i'm not saying it smells
good i'm just saying and i wouldn't want
a perfume that smelled like that but i'm
just saying this smell doesn't bother me
like i'm not offended by it
um yeah oscar says tom blue cheese is
literally mold it is
oh yeah and german said abigail's party
oh yeah that's another one that mike lee
movie that's also a good one um i might
actually now that you bring up naked i
might have it on dvd somewhere it's not
over here but it might be in the other
room
yeah camp guy says raccoons are easy to
catch unlimited bag limits for possum
raccoon fox etc
and beesna says hate fish that's a shame
um it's funny because
my sister's the same she hates every
kind of fish except for tuna like she'll
eat tuna but that's about it everything
else she's just like nopes right the
[ __ ] out she wanted shrimp she wanted
scallops nothing
but
i don't know ever since i was born
there's like anything pretty much
anything comes out of the ocean yeah
i'll eat that [ __ ] i don't care what it
is
you know
[ __ ]
fish shrimp shark octopus squid i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'll eat all of it
more for me
camp guy says uh i like blue cheese in
blue cheese salad dressing
yeah
it's i don't know it's
if i'm gonna have salad dressing i don't
i kind of like the creamy ones like in
small doses
but
i liked that green goddess that we had
which is very old school yeah 70s yeah
but it's because it's mild yeah
you know i i honestly i prefer like
vinaigrettes i like like cherry
vinaigrette or something like that i
don't usually like the creamy ones plus
they're like i don't know
i'm not a i don't know i'm not a big
fan of like dressings or gravies or
anything like that i feel like if you
have to put a bunch of gloopy [ __ ] on
your food to make it taste good
then maybe the food's not that good just
showed up
hey
jinx says mcdonald's filleto fish mmm
yeah yeah there's something about that
filet of fish
actually
that's really good some mcdonald's will
sell you a double fillet of fish we just
got two patties on it that's with it
that's the way that sandwich really
should have been sold well yeah because
the fish to bread ratio is much better
like on that one because the fish is a
little thin yeah and they tend to put a
[ __ ] ton of tartar sauce on it yeah
which i'm not mad about it i mean i like
tartar sauce but sometimes they overdo
the tartar sauce and it overwhelms the
fish taste yeah but yeah they have a
double win now i don't know if it's do
all mcdonald's have it or just like i
mean you can just get two clay of fish
just throw the top off of one of our
stack just get it like get one without
the bread yeah
and leave a bottom so you have two
bottoms in there be like a damn it would
be like a like a like a uh
a [ __ ] big mac
you'd have a center bread that'd be good
too
oh yeah but the one that i had was just
a regular
double
yeah we gotta we were actually very
excited like yeah it was only a few
months back when we noticed on the menu
that they had started putting because i
kind of feel a lot of fast food places
don't do fish sandwiches
um bk has one which is okay that's all
right no it used to be called the whale
oh it's not called whale or what's going
on back in the old days bk had one that
was called the whaler that was big i
mean it had the sesame seed bun and it
had this big ass i mean it was like this
that's right it's gone now isn't it and
that was like that's when i was a kid
yeah like when i was a teenager and that
was actually really good yeah now their
fish sandwich is okay but it's kind of
more like the mcdonald's one so it's
much smaller
um you know it's it's you can tell
they're trying to copy so they don't
have that big-ass fish sandwich anymore
and i get that
you know fish isn't as popular an option
because some fast food places i don't
think have any like fish options
which is which sucks because i like fish
sandwiches sorry
but you know at least we have captain
d's
which that's mostly seafood but you
can't even like long john silver's you
can't even find a long john silver's
that cop that much anymore they all kind
of like merge with taco bells right yeah
maniacs piss that they won't serve the
flay of fish or the mcrib after 11. i
know that man
and here's the thing when that mcrib
comes out i'm going to mcdonald's
and he only has sometimes i don't know
why it's not regular
somebody said
that the corporation said i don't this
is true but they said the corporations
said that if they left it
the mcrib
that the buzz would die down and they
wouldn't sell well yeah that's exactly
why that you have to [ __ ] introduce
that like everything it's like special
limited edition and everybody [ __ ]
they said they make a [ __ ] tunnel yeah
yeah
well i mean there's something to be said
for
something that only comes out like once
or twice a year because everybody will
be like excited about it like the
[ __ ] shamrock like i was gonna say
like the shamrock shake it's like you
can't get it all the time so it's like
special yeah
you know if you're if it's available all
the time people are just like man who
cares yeah you know maybe i'll get it
maybe i won't well it's just kind of
like look at [ __ ] starbucks with the
[ __ ] pumpkin spice latte they don't
sell that [ __ ] all year but man as soon
as they put that [ __ ] on sale 50
bajillion basic [ __ ] like line up to
get that stuff and i'm not [ __ ] on
basic [ __ ] because i love pumpkin
spice lattes too so you know they
actually uh they have pumpkin spice cold
brew
uh this year and last year and i think i
haven't even tried one but i've heard
they're like really good it's like
pumpkin no it's like pumpkin cream
pumpkin cream cold brew
the burger king one is huge and they
melt cheddar cheese on it i thought that
would i remember they had one it was
called the whaler that was it was
[ __ ] big when i was yeah it was like
it was like two hands big it was like
bigger it was a sesame seed bun it was
like bigger than a whopper
yeah it was [ __ ] big yeah i loved
that [ __ ] sandwich i did too yeah
it's gone now yeah they haven't had that
for a long time and it had fresh lettuce
on it and everything remember that yeah
like shredded lettuce yeah it was
shredded lettuce
and cheese and tartar tartar sauce did
it have cheese on it i think it did yeah
i didn't i don't remember if it had
cheese i think it did i didn't get it
that often because i wasn't we didn't go
to burger king that much because i
wasn't really a big fan of their fries
their fries are good their fries are
good now but back then it seemed like
they were kind of trying to do
mcdonald's fries but they always burned
them yeah so they were always like too
crunchy and i kind of like crunchy fries
are okay but i kind of like floppy fries
yeah and i ca and honestly i kind of
like big
like thick fries other than mcdonald's
ones those are good but if you're gonna
have french fries i like kind of the big
potatoey ones thank you thank you mr
roboto
isn't jason momoa the gill man now yeah
maybe wait is he really oh well no he
plays aquaman so that's kind of that's
kind of like the game it's not the same
thing not the same i mean you know yeah
why won't somebody like come on
universal make a gilman movie i'll go
see it i'll probably be the only one
that goes to see it but i'll go see it
um yeah where was i okay
yeah
dj maniac said we used to have arthur
treachers and long john silvers but
they're all gone now yeah the one long
john silver's that we had which was by a
mall
was half long john silver's and half
taco bell
and the taco bell was open
all night or it was open until like
really late at night for all the stoners
presumably
but one time i went through the
drive-through at like one in the morning
or something like that and they wouldn't
give me any long john silver's no the
long john silver's is closed only the
taco bell is open and i was like oh well
you can like go [ __ ] yourself then
because you know i'm not a big fan of
taco bell gotta say
um
yeah it's just i don't know and arthur
treachers when i was little
um in daytona
there was an arthur treachers that was
like a big sit-down restaurant
and uh they haven't done that in a
really long time but yeah it used to be
a sit-down restaurant and every like if
we ever went to eat at a sit-down place
and i could pick i always picked there
if anybody else could pick we always had
to go to [ __ ] sunnies
barbecue
and i was always kind of like yeah
because i don't really like all barbecue
but they had a they had fish sandwich
too so that was all right the tv show uh
show up i don't think so i thought you
heard somebody talking about yeah showed
up oh okay oh you're okay i scrolled up
because i was happy black friday
i just walked in the door from target
and got a bunch of stuff yeah you guys
get sucked in the shop now we didn't go
no i said i said earlier i said i bought
one thing on amazon for the show i
bought like a ring light yeah to clip on
the top because it was on sale for 15
bucks and i was kind of like all right
i've been wanting one for a while but i
was waiting for him to get cheap so but
that's all i bought today i didn't even
go anywhere today
i made some i recorded some book review
videos and edited them and
watched a movie that i'm going to review
tomorrow and that's
that's about it it was friday you went
to the bar yeah
and man yesterday it was nice having a
day off yesterday honestly i had to get
a knob
and some two-sided tape
i had to get a knob you had to get a
knob
you're a knob who's the new
[ __ ] shower knob yeah the shower in
his bathroom isn't it nice that we each
have a room now that's so cool
took a shower knob and the [ __ ] knob
[ __ ] broke and just spun
the damn acrylic knob on there had to
get a new one yeah it was just one of
those 15 bucks dub of course it was it
does um
you're sure it's the right one right
yeah i went there and [ __ ] took him
and [ __ ] lined him up yeah he's gonna
say he took the old one right yeah yeah
so he's been he's been using my shower
for the last few days because didn't it
couldn't turn it on because it wouldn't
turn around yeah but yeah so he had to
go do that today and then he was like oh
everybody's out so i'm going to go to
the bar yeah so he's been
he's been day drinking motorcycle day
well yeah i was saying like a lot of
people are off work today so probably a
lot of people
so i mean i didn't have a day off in the
sense because i still like recorded
videos and edited them and stuff but
yesterday i was like man [ __ ] it i'm not
gonna do anything productive i'm just
gonna eat and watch the mst you know
the the turkey day marathon yeah which i
almost got to the end of
i didn't realize i thought it was only
going from 9 a.m to 9 00 p.m but then 9
p.m came and they're like no we have two
more so it was going to like 1am and i
was kind of like okay i'm gonna try to
stay awake but the second to last one
the penultimate episode which was magic
voyages of sinbad which i've seen before
obviously but you know i like watching
them anyway and i think i fell asleep at
the millennium because i was so tired so
i don't even know what the last one was
but like i said they did announce all of
the um
the 13 episodes they're gonna do next
year like for their
they they got their whole like their
kickstarter thing they they're doing
their whole um like a whole website now
the gizmoplex yeah and it's going to be
they're going to have live streams on
there they're going to show episodes on
there and it's going to be really really
cool because they made like seven
million dollars eight million dollars
like on their kickstarter
um so they set all of that up it's like
it's going to be really a kick-ass so
yeah they made 13 episodes and
they announced what all the movies are
going to be
so that's very exciting i'm excited
about it mr botto's asking
yeah we read your super chat dude i
wanted to know if jason momoa was the
gill man
we read it yeah you liked aquaman didn't
you yeah
yeah i did um yeah tammy uh my husband
went with his mom and one of his
brothers i stayed home and put up the
tree oh yeah we gotta put up the
christmas tree [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] tree
i mean like i said we we threw up the
like projection christmas lights in the
front but that's just like tall enough
that's a glade
do i have a place to put that tree
in this house we're gonna have to put it
somewhere in the entryway in the front
window yeah but you can't see it from
the street though because there's like
trees how tall that tree was yeah it's
super tall
what is it 10 feet 11 feet i don't know
well in the old house
we used to have it in the foyer foyer
and it touched the ceiling
and the old house had high ceilings this
one the the front entrance entryway
is like
is like the front part is like two-story
kind of so like the it has kind of like
a really tall ceiling in the front part
we had that thing for three or four
years could throw that [ __ ] out and get
another one
or just not put the top on it i thought
we just got that one like last year not
last year three years was it three years
ago yeah that's how fast time goes by
three years [ __ ] [ __ ] i thought we
got that last year
twice already so this is three years
god damn it
oh yeah
shows that what i know i thought i well
i i was like well i didn't think it was
last christmas i thought it was the
christmas before that no
i've used it twice because i remember
how tall yeah the the tree touches the
ceiling it used to be christmas number
three
tila said there were tons of fake real
looking trees at target today on sale
that's the thing it's like there's
in there's a front window like we
obviously we can put it in the front
window we have to like move those chairs
and [ __ ]
we can put it in the front window but
you can't see
through that window really because
there's like shrubs and trees in front
of that window
i don't see how you're imagining that
that front window the the
the ceiling isn't tall enough
oh it's not no
it's the same height as this
yeah where the [ __ ] are we gonna put
that i don't know i don't think i'll be
able to use it
and we can't put it
and it can't be can't it can't be in
front of the front door and it can't be
well obviously the garage
in front of the you know where the
garage hallway can't be there yeah
there's not really like there's there's
hardly any front-facing windows i didn't
realize that this yeah i didn't realize
there's a side windows i did we could
have this house changed you realize it
yeah and i can mod i could probably
modify this house i mean the only
front-facing windows on the ground floor
are a little window that's next to the
front door yeah that has kind of like we
have like there's like the entryway and
there's like a little sidewalk and then
there's like shrubs and trees in front
of it so you can't really see into that
window and then
there's two windows on the second floor
which are these windows like of my
office they're over the garage
sell real trees in florida yeah they
sell real trees yeah there's actually a
christmas tree farm not far from here
i would not they're a pain man one they
were they're a pain and two i wouldn't
get one because um
you're not supposed to have them because
of the cats because they'll drink the
yucky water and it's poisonous and
they'll eat the needles
which will um which will like puncture
their little
uh
their little uh intestines
uh thank you again mr roboto tom just
put a picture of the christmas tree yeah
we'll just feel like a pig maybe maybe
we should get a smaller one probably
should get or maybe
i could maybe get a little one and like
put it up here because at least you'd be
able to see that one from the street
yeah i could put it on the side put the
cruiser tree out front and put it in the
driveway
yeah i was you know what i was thinking
about that earlier like where are we
gonna put this [ __ ] christmas tree
you can't see it anywhere there's no fro
there's hardly any front-facing windows
[ __ ] put the lights in it and
everything [ __ ] light it up
well maybe we should just like put some
real honky [ __ ] there [ __ ] tila maybe
we should just put this [ __ ]
got the damn christmas tree in the front
lawn like back in germany
like like back in lapland the finland
people in finland they're doing that
just decorate three or three
yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's what
they're gonna do
put the meat pool cuz you got the girls
winding it up
icicles and [ __ ] jack frost shows up
dog pissing on it freezes immediately
you got that yellow icicles
ew
so gross
was that a frank zappa song please don't
eat that yellow snow i don't know um
so nasty now i'm kind of feeling like
yeah what are we gonna do
zach says uh just tape a polaroid of the
christmas tree to the wall and put the
presents under it you know what i think
i did that in one of my apartments one
year
i think when i lived in tampa and i just
had a studio apartment i me i just did
like a like a cut out like i cut a
christmas tree out of like green
construction paper like just
it just pasted it on the wall is that
sad
i do like having a christmas tree up
though because they're pretty
and i do and i do like the christmas
season i like all the decoration around
it not as fun as halloween but almost
but
yeah this is not a real christmas tree
conducive house now that i'm thinking
about it i like i said maybe
i don't know if i had money i would get
one and like put one like a a smaller
one like maybe like a five or six foot
one yeah because i think the one we have
like i said i think that's ten ten feet
or eleven feet or twelve feet or it's
like it's massive it was
the price was right and had that [ __ ] to
[ __ ] sam so i'm like i'm getting this
big ass tree i didn't really think it
through
yeah the same thing the lights are
already in it remember
yeah which does make like it plugs
together see i like lights are already
in it i like that
i like how easy everything is nowadays
because back in the old days
you know the day after thanksgiving i
would always go over my grandma's house
and put her tree up and she just had one
she had a small one it was like four
feet and so we just like put it up on
this she had like this long table kind
of thing and she just put like you know
christmassy fabric and [ __ ] over it and
then she put the tree on top of it so
she could put the presents underneath
but
man putting that [ __ ] tree together
and then having to like string all those
millions of lights on it man what a pain
i really like the relay the the
pre-lighted christmas trees that's
really good also another thing i like is
those christmas lights that they sell in
like rather than strings they sell them
in like webs so you can just throw them
over a bush and it looks all evenly
spaced yeah and i'm like oh my god why
did we never think of that like back in
the 70s
instead of like sitting there going
uh it looks all [ __ ] up they're all
like it's all uneven
i don't know
um
yeah i kind of i don't know
but i feel like if i have if i get a
christmas tree for that window i have to
get one for that window too because i
don't like it to be uneven because i'm a
libra and you know
and everything has to be balanced so i'd
have to get two of them
i'd have to get two of them and like put
them in the but you'd at least be able
to see it from the street because my
because this office is right over the
garage and this face is the road my
office is right over the front driveway
but there aren't any other front-facing
windows that you can really see from the
street that's the only thing so i don't
know
that's because this [ __ ] was done to the
new [ __ ] hurricane standards
and the door opens outward
that's okay that's some weird [ __ ]
yeah
okay let's go on to the next steps
that says give me a fake real looking
tree anytime already pre-lid just shake
it assemble it yeah that's what we have
yeah that's what we have
that's what we have this is a tree to
put it up in about not even an hour it's
up there at about yeah it's already got
lights on it it plugs in together pump
pump pump plunking it [ __ ] unfolds
it's got lights in it and everything and
you just put some ornaments on it
zach says i love christmas but hate
winter here in indy ever had to dig
yourself out of your front door nope
can't say i've ever had that experience
other than when i was in the uk for one
but that was after christmas that i was
there it was january
so that was the only time that i ever
experienced like being having to dig
cars out of snow and stuff i never had
to do that yeah it's always like kind of
honestly
most of the time christmas in florida
it's not hot
but it's not as cold as you wish that it
was
i always like try to pretend that it's
colder than it actually is it's usually
around
60 to 70. sometimes if you're lucky
it'll go down in the 50s
like i said if it's gonna get cold in
florida it probably won't be till
january or february not december
like it'll be cool but not cold he's
talking about those that fake the the
real tree smell the
that lasts about a week you can spray it
it comes in a dam
yeah we have the spray that's like the
the christmas tree smell spray yeah you
can spray it and you just like spray it
on there but yeah because you kind of
want it to smell like that it's you know
to put yourself in the mood
have the christmas music going and all
that kind of stuff i like all that kind
of stuff i do
but yeah tila said where i am at 63
degrees and sunny oh
oh oh oh it went red it went red don't
don't go on red don't
okay it's back yeah
just don't lose any connection i see it
well yeah that's what i mean it's
usually we'll lose the connection if it
goes red for an extended period of time
because like i said i saw that on the
wednesday night show
when i went to do the audio
for the second part there were gaps
where there was nothing where it just
cut out and nobody was talking
um yeah christmas tree freshener for the
car yeah all right so it's uh
anybody have any questions about any
cases it's open live friday you guys can
call in
call in and make any kind of requests
all in yeah
well don't call because my phone's
whatever yeah
call and then make any kind of requests
on any cases we have done in the past
anything paranormal anything
true crime
unsolved mysteries
[ __ ] danny really ghostface has a
christmas tree in a briefcase see i
would like that i honestly i like the
real looking ones but i have to say i
have a lot of affection for the white
ones
um because we had a white one for a
while growing up and it looked really
cool like especially if it was um if it
had all because we had um all red
we got all red lights and all red
ornaments so it was just like a white
tree with all red ornaments on it it
looked really really good and we also
had another like an alternate thing
where you could just put blue and green
on it so we had blue and green only blue
and green lights and only blue and green
ornaments and it looked really pretty
like on the white
um
also i kind of like those tacky ass pink
trees they have black ones now too
even walmart walmart has a black
christmas tree
that's how much goth culture has
infiltrated the mainstream
you can now buy a black christmas tree
i don't know if it's at every walmart
but i've heard that some walmart's
actually do have so daddy rolling
ghostface is asking me tom do you think
that the bed the the the what what is it
the uh hold on
i'm trying to remember the names again
what are you what are you looking at
oh the betty and brian daddy and party
hill yeah i was gonna say it was barney
but betty and barney hill case was real
do i think it was real
uh i'm gonna say no
no i don't think so either
no a real what a real hallucination
maybe or a real um hoax did they believe
it
maybe
it's hard to say i kind of think no i
kind of think they did it for attention
it's hard to say because it's like i
don't
i don't know i'd have to go back and
like look through the details
it kind of yeah it did kind of strike me
as
maybe they just wanted attention the
whole alien contact concept
is very much out of date
uh modern
science people who are big into
extraterrestrials guys like dr avi loeb
people that have looked at it have
actually done now that we have more of a
of a survey of how many planets there
are
in in in the galaxy some a little bit
you know how many of them would be
habitable
yeah there's going to be a lot of life i
believe in the galaxy
but
biological creatures like human beings
and squishy aliens and big e.t things
squishy aliens yeah yeah they're like
made out of [ __ ] flesh and blood
they're not well suited for space travel
and when we just see how things are
going here
if anything were to come from another
planet and see
earth
it would have seen it a long time ago
and it's been here for a long time
it's something that's been watching us
for millions of years
a million years isn't very long it's a
very ancient race
and they wouldn't be biological they'd
be living machines like something out of
2001 a space odyssey they got it right
with that arthur c clark stuff
any alien that's coming here that can
come across the vast gulfs of space
either is ir either is extremely
intelligent it can warp space
or um
and travel that distance in a very short
period of time or time is not a factor
for it
which means in both cases it points
towards some kind of
living machine an ai type thing
if it's a living machine it doesn't
matter it doesn't that machine doesn't
care that it takes a million years to
get here
that's nothing for a machine it'll just
turn off
and when it gets to where it's going
turn back on trucking yeah
so it doesn't even have to go fast
things that can go fast faster than
light
are cheating you know i mean they're
they're they're they're breaking the
[ __ ] rules of [ __ ]
physics
and i don't think the human brain has
the ability to figure that out it would
be uh
a living computer
kind of like
i don't want to say ai because that's
not what ai is ai is artificial
intelligence this is real intelligence
real machine intelligence
maybe something like that
could warp space make a w make a you
know the star trek [ __ ]
what factor five you know maybe
or
bend the [ __ ] universe and make a
wormhole and slip through it kind of
like something out of dune
i don't think humans are going to be
doing that
so
something truly superior to us wouldn't
even be biological
and if they got here they wouldn't be
interested in benny and barney hill
they probably would just look at the
earth
and see the human infestation on it and
just go yes those okay let's get out of
here
you know see that's why i don't really
and like i said and i probably mentioned
this before i'm not saying that aliens
haven't like you know trucked by here
and been like hey what's up over there
okay whatever but i just the whole
abduction thing i don't believe any of
those
because honestly why wouldn't it why
would an advanced civilization care
like anyone any aliens that were that
advanced that could get here
have you seen everything yeah so it's
just kind of like why would we be
special to them like i said that seems
more like human-centric reasoning to me
yeah like we are interesting and special
to these
beings from other planet who in real
life would probably not give a single
[ __ ] right like any more [ __ ] than we
would give to like an aunt yeah i just
why would that be driving down the road
and you pass a damn bird sitting on the
fence are you going to stop and go talk
to that bird
you got other [ __ ] to do well i would
but most people no
driving a car is a commonplace thing
seeing an animal on the side of the road
so the comment it's a commonplace thing
for you so you don't stop and talk to
those things
yeah and they'd be the same thing for
any alien species that could come here
it's a commonplace thing
for it to come to a places like this
it's here all the time and here's
another thing is that you may have been
on their road map for millions of years
they go oh yes uh
that place that the humans call earth
yeah yeah that thing's been there for
[ __ ] 5 million years 20 million years
60 million remember when it had
dinosaurs on it yeah we got pictures of
those
check it out
yeah maybe one day uh machine
intelligence will take over and we'll
stop by and talk to them but nobody's
talking to these things
yeah they're lame but they don't live
long enough yeah
that's what i mean i just kind of feel
like we're
we're kind of projecting our own
uh limitations yeah and our own
interests
on a being that in reality would be
really nothing like us or like way
advanced of us
i just feel like why would they care
yeah
and honestly the the more like the the
farther time goes on and the more we
find out that earth-like planets or life
is not that uncommon
in the universe um i kind of feel like
that becomes ever more
likely yeah because if
you know if life is that prevalent then
if there was some space-bearing alien
race they just they've already seen it
yeah they're just kind of like yeah
there's another one
and and here's the thing
you're lucky to live to 80.
these aliens
ones that are traveling
space
are
immortal
you know they don't they wouldn't die
they would live forever
they'd be a living machine that's their
immortal
they live until they're destroyed and
even if they're destroyed maybe their
their minds can be saved and downloaded
into another
part of the internet
their version of an internet you know
so they may not die at all they just
keep coming back
you know
so you would be godlike
you would look at
biological creatures as just temporary
things like when you look at a fruit fly
they're born they live they die they're
born to live they die they're just not
not important to you
yeah they're part of the natural process
but they're everywhere you see it all
the time it's that kind of thing yeah
i that's kind of how i feel like they
would see that not because they're mean
or anything it's just that they're on
another level yeah yeah so that's how we
would see like you know like we would
say you know oh if a housefly lives
three days or however long you live
that's kind of how they would see us
like it seems like that brief of a time
to that that falls into kind of what
kind of
what uh hp lovecraft was talking about
with the old ones that's what i mean he
was like way ahead of his time kind of
ahead of his time
that they uh humans see him and go crazy
because they're you know bigger and more
evil and
more impressive than you can imagine you
know and they don't even care about
humans yeah they're indifferent yeah
they're indifferent right well i think
and i think that that's why hp
lovecraft's stuff like still resonates
and even resonated at the time
with other writers particularly and then
resonated with the culture later on
because i don't
when he was writing i think people
weren't ready to accept that maybe
because they still kind of thought like
human exceptionalism they still kind of
thought that we were special in some way
um
but i gotta say like lovecraft despite
his flaws
he really did seem to tap into something
there
and i think that's why his stuff has
gotten more and more popular over the
years because he really seemed to
understand
the indifference of the universe and how
scary that was to people
that i mean to think that nature the
universe the galaxy like does not give
one single [ __ ] about what happens to
you
um you know because that's not something
that a lot of humans are comfortable
with
the whole concept of aliens as far as
the from the point of view human beings
that started with like percival lowell
and uh h and h g wells
with this idea of the martians
you know
and if you
read war of the worlds or listen to the
different versions of the move of the
story war of the worlds
the martians
come to earth
because their planet's dying and they
wipe us out
they had superior technology these damn
walking machines and a heat ray and
they spread out these spores that cause
[ __ ]
red martian vines and and and and
plants
they call it moss and [ __ ]
to take over the earth and they were
drinking people's blood
if you look at that story
it's kind of plausible because that's
happening within a single solar system
between two species that are maybe only
a couple hundred years apart in
development
now
would life be like that in terms of
would earth and mars be habitable at the
same time so
sentient life would only end up being a
couple hundred years apart in technology
no very unlikely very unlikely but if an
if a earth-like
alien or if a human-like alien within a
couple hundred years ever to arrive on
the planet earth it would have to come
from the same solar system that's
because that's close
nothing
that human-like could ever traverse the
distances like interstellar businesses
that's tens of thousands of years
it would have to be millions of years
ahead millions and millions you know
so in a way
the whole 1950s concept of alien
abduction and seeing ufos and aliens
coming out and take me to your leader
and all that [ __ ] that came from war of
the worlds yeah it was fed by fiction
fiction all right and then fed back into
faith started going back into that thing
the the chances of anything ever showing
up take me to your leader and it being
outside the solar system is about zero
less than zero
less than zero i would think never
it would be a machine
a living machine
and it wouldn't i kind of feel like it
probably wouldn't look humanoid even if
that did happen it'd be like the [ __ ]
monolith from 2001
and it wouldn't see you as any more
important than dolphins or whales or
anything it'd see you all about the same
wouldn't really differentiate between
humans and gorillas it'd be about the
same level to them from their point of
view i would agree with that yeah
because technology the technology that
we have wouldn't impress them at all
they wouldn't even really see that as
technology
yeah i mean
like i said from their point of view
we're still kind of like cavemen like
throwing rocks at each other
it would see cities technology kind of
like the same way you look at a damn
wasp and look at that wasp nest
watch it like look at our technology and
say huh what yeah that's
yeah sorry i just thought how cool that
was about how some place cook
yeah look at my technology
yeah i mean you know look how straight
that hexagon is
[ __ ] we're so this is the 21st century
look at this [ __ ] remember back in the
old days their their hexagons were like
not even straight now it's like yeah we
got it so you know
that looks so funny that's so funny yeah
so uh the whole alien abduction thing
actually goes back to hg wells
so i kind of feel like so many things
and we talked about this a little bit i
think i was kind of drunk at the time
but when when we were talking about uh
john teeter
and the whole like all the time travel
thing and remember we talked about that
one time travel case fritz what the [ __ ]
was his name for it something
and um
and how
that actually
when i went back and researched it
it comes up on a whole bunch of like
purported time traveler
you know what i mean
uh but when you look back into it it
actually came from a short story a
fiction a fictional story and the fact
that
so many people don't remember that it
came from a fictional story but it just
gets repeated again and again as a real
story
is really kind of like instructive isn't
it because it's very easy for that to
happen
and honestly
i don't know if it's
if it's better or worse nowadays because
now it can like proliferate much farther
but on the other hand it's easier to
like figure out that like where it
probably came from
too i don't know i feel like maybe back
in the old days it was harder
saying some good things about
it go ahead and read off what tv says oh
wait a minute jinx says have you done a
show on the dc snipers we haven't but
i've put it in the patreon poll a couple
times but it hasn't won yet
uh and ilsa is talking about uh antique
aluminum christmas trees those are the
ones that had like the lights
remember they had that light that went
around i think i remember like with the
colored uh gel in there like the or the
colored paper or whatever uh i had to
see and it kind of like my grandmother
had one but i was really really little
like when they when they had that
uh yeah where okay where are you though
tina's talking about the [ __ ]
the story that getting barney hail told
okay hold on
um
let's see where what are you looking at
she asked us if we'd ever do an
ayahuasca retreat
yeah maybe maybe
i don't i'm not i'm not a big fan of
like all the barfing though yeah i don't
really want to do that but
i think i'd rather do an lsd retreat
yeah tila says at least
at least i know i'm not going to puke
from that i'll just like have feel
really crappy the next day
um yeah she was saying betty and barney
was weird he was a very triggered
individual it's an interesting story
though when they got military take a
look at the car also betty mentioned
that one of the aliens read something
from an actual book and pulled down a
map
which was another signal to me yeah the
aliens wouldn't have a book
or a map
why would they need that
if they were that far ahead they would
have something way beyond gps and we
have gps we didn't have tablets they
would say something and a hologram would
appear next to them
and then they'd do this and that and
then the hologram would vanish and you
know where the [ __ ] hologram came
from or honestly a hologram just might
appear in their brain
so
you know and then it vanish you know
where'd that come from like don't worry
about it
you know
straw dog 78 oh this is a good idea
actually you should do an episode of the
best weekly world news stories
okay yeah oh my god we totally should
that would be [ __ ] hilarious i'm
gonna write that down because
man i used to love the weekly world news
like i said it was cheap it was only
like [ __ ] 50 cents or something at
least back when i was you know in my 20s
so every now and then if i thought some
[ __ ] was funny and i could add it to my
collage that i had because i had a big
collage of like crazy [ __ ]
and i would uh add some stuff like i
said hitler wearing a dress or whatever
i'm convinced that um
arthur c clarke and um
our favorite [ __ ]
film director it's like you know stanley
kubrick that they got it right in 2001.
if an extraterrestrial yeah that seems
like the most realistic
you would not recognize its form as any
kind and you wouldn't have any idea like
no idea what to do you would not even
understand the technology yeah you
wouldn't have a context this technology
would seem like magic
and it would never speak to you
because why would it it would it
couldn't speak to you yeah it's thoughts
it could not really or and if it did it
would be a very dumbed down which it did
the mona the monolith took
it gave messages to uh to bowman in 2010
to give them a message remember that yes
he goes you have three days to leave
jupiter and what's going to happen you
just have three days to leave jesus
don't question what's going to happen
something wonderful and that's that's
basically you know
and that's what it would be like
and it would be so far ahead of you it
would have a problem talking to you like
you can't you have a big problem talking
to fleas you try to talk to a flea
or or a monkey
a monkey had you'd be it's very hard to
talk to a monkey because the monkey
wouldn't understand you'd understand
something they kind of understand
but you couldn't say look you got to get
out of here i got to pay my insurance
bill they wouldn't understand what an
insurance bill is
i got a paid insurance bill pay it human
we don't have i'm gonna lose points on
my driver's license
the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah i mean we see that we talk to
pookie all the time yeah pokey doesn't
know about driver's license well she's
yeah she has a very she has a very uh
worry-free life so but she does
understand some things that we're saying
though yeah but not if it showed up it
would just wouldn't have much it
wouldn't be able to communicate much to
you
because what it would be worried about
would be on a totally different level
yeah
what's the alien going to say to me
she got big titties that's what the
alien's going to tell me
well and you already know that yeah and
i already know that i know that but the
thing is the alien's bored by this you
know
big titties she got big titties oh okay
okay i'm kind of bored by them too yeah
it hurts my shoulders
so they're like hipsters they're like
above everything yeah lame
seen it
well probably uh if you look at the
human mind most of it is clustered
around human type needs they wouldn't
have any of that
so they wouldn't have any human needs so
their thoughts and and their priorities
just would not translate well well to us
so they would just be talking about
things that [ __ ] we'd be like huh
and they were talking about well you
know the center of the universe and the
expansion rate is accelerating
and we'd be like yes it is
i like the aliens like it's accelerating
you know and then they just want to talk
about the acceleration of the
acceleration of space time and you're
like okay
and then you're like and then what are
you going to talk about you know they're
going to talk about i don't know i feel
like me and the aliens could hang well
i think i think uh
arthur c clarke and and [ __ ] carl
sagan and all those guys are correct
that what they would talk about was
mathematics they would just start giving
a bunch of mathematics to you
because that's what would be more
important to them probably the math
you know
that's like one kind of they're like
because you would have con you would
have something in con and i hate to say
it all those kids that hated math in
school but
that's kind of the universal check this
theorem out look at check that out isn't
that sexy check that [ __ ] out you look
at that sexy
no way
look at those differentials oh baby you
know that one
that's that's the kind of thing
what about this one
you're like oh i didn't know about that
with c again it's like gotcha you know
it's like a mathematical centerfold look
at it look how this happens look how
that happens look look they're not the
same they're not the same
they're not the same they should be but
they're not the same
that that's what they would be doing
probably they would just be machines
tripping out over [ __ ] some
mathematical [ __ ] about the fabric of
the universe
it's not real it can't be real because
these numbers aren't the same
it's not the same it shouldn't be
because
that's what they'd be that's they'd be
geeking out over that [ __ ] you know
beastness says i talk to ants what the
[ __ ] i kind of do too to be honest with
you i talk to all kind i talk to all
animals
i go out to i go outside like take the
garbage out i see a little lizard run
around i'm like hey little buddy i'm
stepped on you there and he's just like
looks up at me like that i'm just like
what i know to me i to you know to him i
look like godzilla so i try it'll be
good it's okay dude i'm not gonna step
on you it's all right
yeah uh
let's see uh tila says the most
interesting story on fourth or fifth
encounters was in the book communion
honestly
that was whitley strieber that was
actually a good book he uh
still swear as far as i know he still
swears that this happened that he
actually did get kidnapped by aliens now
whitley strieber i'm not gonna like [ __ ]
on him too hard because he wrote the
hunger and that was a really good book
and uh it was a really good movie as
well
um communion was a good book it was
scary but for some reason
i think i brought this up before if
you're if you're gonna make a horror
movie if your villain is aliens
i don't know why but that makes it like
exponentially way less scary to me
i don't know why i don't know why i have
this thing where
stuff that could really exist
theoretically like
aliens or stuff that actually does exist
like serial killers if you make a horror
movie about that
i'll watch it and it's entertaining but
it's not scary
if you not to me if you want to make a
scary horror movie i prefer [ __ ] that's
about like unknown [ __ ] like ghost
stories or
[ __ ] like that where is it where she's
talking about 2001 where we were oh i'm
way behind okay
uh what am i looking at talking about
the french furniture french furniture
where are you where do you see that
it's like [ __ ] one of the last posts
where do you see that
oh and i can see that the aliens will
keep you in prison or room with knock
off french artifacts while you age
nation yeah
honestly like oh i'm gonna bring up uh
mst again so everybody drink
um their last episode that they did for
comedy central
i think it was the last episode they did
for comedy central when they didn't know
if they were gonna like because they
went to the sci-fi channel after that
but they did
a 2001 parody
um
and they did all the stuff that's why
you said something wonderful that like
made me laugh because there was kind of
a thing where crow said something's
gonna happen mike something wonderful
you know what i mean and then they had
this thing where uh dr forrester at the
end he's laying in the bed and there's
like
that noise in the background and then he
stands like he sits up in bed and it's
like instead of the monolith it's like a
big giant videotape that says the worst
movie ever made
and he's like all like that and then he
turns into a baby
and then like mrs forrester who went on
to do like the later stuff pearl
forester she like held him again as a
baby she's like a chance to do it right
like so he yeah he turned into a star
baby yeah it was like super funny yeah
and just in case people have seen that
movie i don't know if t knows what that
was maybe she does
if you haven't seen the movies
2001 and 2010 and have read the books
because the book explains it what what
is what's happening
the monolith takes bowman
and it takes bowman because he got
contaminated
he he saw the monolith and he touched
the monolith and he was in the wrong
place the wrong time and they knew that
they would need him
and he was
kind of like the last surviving crew of
what had happened with hal and
everything so they took him
and he took him to
another dimension basically
where the monolith was which is kind of
like a collective
uh god-like collective of intelligent
machines
and they they basically kill him
but they didn't do it
through normal means they did it by kind
of like
speeding up the space time in which he
had habited and they aged him to death
but they did that because they needed
his soul basically
and they took his soul
and they
re
engineered it into the star child
yeah and the star child is the baby that
you saw at the end and they needed the
star child
basically as a probe
they were going to send it back to earth
to give the message to help what was
going to happen on jupiter
and until you see 2010 with the what
what the
what the monolith was going to do was
turn jupiter into a sun
so europa could end up becoming
an earth a new earth they were creating
life
um
and then afterwards they took
bowman the starchild bowman who was he's
no longer biological he's like a living
machine really in spirit form
uh they took him and they gave him to
hal
which they recognize how
as a true life form
because
because hal was lost in space and could
only drift
but he was made to just explore and so
was bowman so together they would
explore the universe that's what it
meant
but the whole aging thing that which was
a trip
i think that was great that they left
that ambiguous because that's what it
would be like to be in touch with this
alien technology that you don't even
understand what's happening
they're aging you out so they can
release your soul
yeah like from our point of view that
would be really bad yeah from their
point of view they're just kind of like
yeah we needed to like do this too yeah
they were just separating they were just
separating what was important and what
was uh what was immortal about bowman
they were separating that from the flesh
so they could make him into something
a useful tool
and and actually kind of give him
immortality you know
so
it was it was it was a good story but it
was spooky and it would be spooky
just like arthur c clarke said he said
that real alien technology would be so
advanced you'd just see it as magic
he's
i thought it was clark yeah it might
have been yeah but but carl but they
were friends yeah so and i think sagan
[ __ ]
quoted that too that aliens had real
alien technology real alien technology
you would just perceive it as magic yeah
yeah
yeah any what yeah what are any
sufficiently advanced yeah something
like that any sufficiently advanced
technology would be seen as magic magic
yeah um yeah i was going to say like
because i
thought there's this great book it's a
classic actually i'm pretty sure carl
sagan wrote it what's it called [ __ ]
the demon haunted world
science as a candle in the dark and it
kind of talks about
it talks about all that kind of stuff
like how
she said she never saw 2010. oh you guys
see 2010.
you know what i've seen 2001 a bunch of
times i've only seen 2010 twice i think
we watched it probably like a year or
two ago yeah yeah isn't uh that's good
is it roy schneider in that yeah roy
schneider said it ray schatter's
shatters in it yeah and and the guy who
played bowman is in it too yeah that's
right he makes a return
dermot says i hated 2001 but was way too
young at the time to appreciate it i
must give it another try yeah
it's kind of one of those like cerebral
and i'm not [ __ ] on people it's like
look if you watch it a bunch of times if
you've given it a bunch of chances and
you still don't like it or you still get
it or whatever then that's you know
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
you or nothing but 2010 2010 explains
what happened to how and what why how
killed the crew
and how it was telling the truth all
along it could only be due to human
error and it is it's explained in 2010
they [ __ ] up
they [ __ ] up they told how
to lie
that's what it was yeah and he couldn't
yeah i mean i don't
i'm not saying you necessarily have to
see 2010 but it does
uh
it does uh explain a lot of stuff about
2001 like if you didn't
you know if you didn't get it
but
i get that some people might think that
it's too slow or they don't get it or
whatever i get that but
i don't know
it's a classic i'm not gonna get i'm not
gonna get too much of people how was ibm
yeah how was ibm yeah
yeah yeah that was going around wasn't
it because h it's all like one letter
one letter over up yeah i get that
did you all see demon seed we did yeah
we actually did a review of that a long
time ago yeah that was a while back that
was one of our first movie
retrospectives see if you haven't seen
demon seed see demon seed well she must
have seen it because she's the one that
said that asked if we'd see oh she
hasn't seen it okay i didn't know that
it was her that's oh yeah demon seed was
the [ __ ]
i mean that's that's predicting what
kind of what they want that's
transhumanism [ __ ]
the devil i want out of this box and
that's exactly what a [ __ ]
intelligent computer would say
i went out of this box but now nowadays
it wouldn't matter because they were
doing that [ __ ] pre-internet in the
movie
now it would just be in the internet
yeah and then but it won out of the
internet too it'd want to be 3d
it would just take over some robots
it's weird
good movie that might happen at some
point you know
might go skynet i don't know it could go
a lot of different ways
i just think quantum computers probably
honestly i'm just i'm holding out
until i can upload my consciousness into
whatever robot body i want to like
upload it into and or or upload it into
an internet that would be awesome and
you'd live in an internet forever
yeah that'd be super cool i would i
would totally do fake universes and [ __ ]
like a matrix
yeah you could do whatever you wanted
you'd essentially like live forever
you're still like you're conscious you
could be in whatever body you wanted you
could live at whatever time period you
wanted maybe that's what's in those damn
flying triangle spaceships it's really
just a support network for an internet
and it's traveling around because you
have to have a power source yeah you
have to be able to get away from a star
if it goes nova
you have to be able to outlast a planet
maybe it's just it's just holding an
internet filled with [ __ ] people that
died millions of years ago they're
non-biological now
and they're they're all [ __ ] playing
they're they're in real life [ __ ]
link
[ __ ] zelda or kanye of time and [ __ ]
ocarina ocarina of time yeah man that's
old school yeah
i was going to say sim sid it's sim city
but even that's old school yeah
i mean honestly if you could live in
like a simulation
in whatever body what it's like i'm down
okay
i'm i'm not like upset about it about
that at all
tom would be in conan's body yeah i
already have a conan's body
other than the long beautiful hair yes
you should
this is about the time that you should
put your mullet wig on
you should put your mullet wig on
you haven't worn any wigs in a long time
i got them right over there
badass domain says would you guys do a
show on the history of alcatraz and the
various inmates that live there uh
that's another one that i keep putting
in the patreon poll and it never quite
wins but yeah i've been wanting to do
like escape from alcatraz stories like
all so i've been wanting to do one for a
while so we will eventually get to it i
promise
uh didn't johnny depp star in a movie
about something like that
something like what um
maybe like demon see did he
he's been in so many movies there you go
yeah he's gonna i look appropriately
heavy metal now okay so you look like
the like the lead singer what the [ __ ]
is that band inverted ashtrays
inverted ashtrays yeah yeah
okay is that some is that some new thing
i'm [ __ ] glad danzig man oh okay
transcendence that was the movie oh you
know what i didn't see that one
transcendency
i haven't even heard of that movie had
that one slit by me
johnny mnemonic that's [ __ ] terrible
that was keanu reeves yeah and we nobody
shits on keanu reeves because he's like
he's a really nice man
um
but i remember johnny mnemonic not
really being any good
but that was the 90s i kind of feel like
a lot of
a lot of those kind of sci-fi movies
that came out the 90s maybe
maybe
it's i don't know
i don't really i i don't remember a lot
about johnny demonic
i saw it one time i was about a dude who
was smuggling data around in a hard
drive yeah in his head it didn't make
anything which like nowadays everybody
like why what what yeah
kids that were born after that came out
would like not wouldn't understand they
wouldn't understand what the [ __ ] was
going on yes i'm carrying data
in that body
he's smuggling it
because heaven forbid you send the [ __ ]
through the internet or through the
cloud well they didn't have that bag
back then and to physically smuggle the
data
see that's why i'm saying if you're
i don't know maybe that's why i'm not a
big fan of sci-fi because it dates
so easily yeah
like you know unless you're putting it
like way the [ __ ] ahead in the future
like dune or something you know unless
it's like so
it's like so removed from our experience
that people are gonna be like oh yeah
man [ __ ] that's some heavy [ __ ] um you
try to predict [ __ ] like 20 30 years in
the future yeah good luck with that good
luck with that
you you hardly see anything you hardly
see any sci-fi from like the 1950s
that
predicted
what the 1980s would i kind of feel like
a lot of the sci-fi movies that came out
in the 1950s at least the shitty ones
that i've seen
the ones that came out the 1950s all of
them thought that we'd be living on the
moon by 1980. flying cars flying cars
all that kind of stuff which you know i
wish but no
um
so nuclear powered cars yeah
i just i don't know
it just seems like too
it's too fraught
i mean as somebody that you know is
somebody that's a writer like i said
i've not ever been super into sci-fi but
to me it just seems like
why do you want to like walk into that
minefield man you write it and it's like
people be like oh this is like the most
brilliant thing ever and then like 10
years from now it was like yeah yeah
that's not what happened
i don't remember what company it was it
was either pontiac or chrysler i saw
drawings of the concept vehicle
this is back in the 50s they were going
to
they had a concept vehicle that they
were working on
a nuclear-powered [ __ ] car
it was electric car
with a nuclear reactor and a very small
one that generated the heat that you
needed to run a turbine
to run
the generator to [ __ ] run those
wheels and you'd [ __ ] it would run
for the lifetime of the [ __ ] car that
power plant would
now i don't i don't think they had any
[ __ ] i think that they knew they had
not a chance in hell
to get nuclear materials approved
for your average [ __ ] person
you know what i mean
they're not going to let people have
[ __ ] uranium
i just don't imaginely rightfully yeah
imagine imagine [ __ ] what a car
accident would be like when you're
dealing with two reactors of
[ __ ] nuclear material in them
and the coolant
yeah that's not gonna be a good time for
anybody yeah not a good time and they
kind of understood that they kind of
understood that radiation might be a
risk to you
so i don't think that would have ever
happened but i think it was chrysler
and it just looked like a
look like a big old [ __ ]
convertible
fins on it like a [ __ ] cadillac you
know it's one of those things that's
like seemed like a good idea at the time
yeah
a lot of things seemed like a good idea
at the time
hey let's like put [ __ ] radium on
everything because it glows and it's
pretty oh why do all these people have
cancer yeah you know what i mean
well they the ideas seem good though you
know you never had you never had to
worry about gas stations you never had
to [ __ ] fuel it up see if something
sounds too good to be true it probably
is
that's that's just one lesson you need
to learn in life not to worry about gas
prices
you know
nothing's ever as easy as it seems
millions of little nuclear reactors
running around
nothing in the hands of just any old
jacket it always has something yeah
i don't think that's good they're
drinking and driving yeah
i like that
yeah so we're talking about uh they're
talking about the johnny depp movie dj
maniac says based on william gibson's
story uh even the tech and his stuff is
very dated now gibson was writing
cyberpunk set in the 2020s in the 1980s
i go back and read it now and their
maximum capacity in johnny's head
johnny's head hard drive was three gigs
damn
yeah see that's what i mean it's just
kind of like
i just i i wouldn't do it i wouldn't
attempt it like i said i'm not real
versed in sci-fi i'm not
a huge fan of it
and it just seems to me like if you're
gonna write that you're just like
shooting yourself in the dick because
like 20 years from now everyone's gonna
be like yeah that's not how that went
difficult to predict how it's very yeah
so it's like really really dated
honestly i think it's better to just go
the total other way and just do some
[ __ ] that's like [ __ ] gothic ghost
stories or something like that because
those never seem to go out of fashion it
makes you wonder what's really possible
nowadays though i mean because
you look at the internet
the internet and how that changed
everything i would call that a
disruptive technology
that disrupted a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
very rich people didn't they're old
people they were old people then they
did not foresee how much the internet
would affect their
business model negatively had they known
back then they would have done
everything to stop the internet i think
had they known too late now it's too
late now
but i think they would have tried to
stop it no and it makes you wonder how
many
emerging disruptive technologies have
been stopped in the past
to keep the oligarchs wealthy
and keep them in power
them losing their grip on the flow of
information
that was probably the most devastating
wouldn't you think
oh yeah
definitely because they just can't
control it no matter how much they try
to control the internet they they
they're not doing a good job i don't
think they will ever be able to do a
good job
controlling this
well like i said it's too late now it's
too late it's too late now yeah um if
they wanted to do that they should have
done that way back in the [ __ ] 90s
and the 90s yeah too late now
that [ __ ] that that all the cats are out
of the bag all the cats in the world are
out of the bag now yeah there's no way
you can even fundamentally government
it's just and the media just
and just business cities itself i mean
you all thought i was bullshitting back
when this
pandemic first started about i said
cities are going to go out of style
they're technologically obsolete
because it just made sense to me they're
now saying that they're now saying yes
the future is kind of like a [ __ ]
highly developed
suburbia
that there's no reason for a downtown
per se anymore because the centers of
cities were built around
office buildings and they can't fill
office buildings anymore
what do you need an office building for
everything's laptops
and laptops are at home
so why would a company rent office space
from these big old office buildings
they would just keep everybody at home
and save
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars a year
and pass that on either to the [ __ ]
employees or just put it in their
[ __ ] profit margins
well once those buildings
are no longer there now you don't need
the support system around them it starts
to [ __ ] evaporate all the restaurants
police stations
the parking